SENATE. COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT WILL
BEGIN. I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA IS WITH US. SO WE HAVE
OUR FIRST PRESENTER. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE, PLEASE. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE EVERYONE SIT AT
THE TABLE AND NOT PRESENT AND
GIVE, WITNESS STATEMENTS AT THE
PODIUM TODAY. WE'LL, WE'LL WE'LL
TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF THIS
BEAUTIFUL ROOM. OKAY. BEFORE WE
GET STARTED, I WANTED TO JUST
MAKE THE ANNOUNCEMENT THAT ITEM
NUMBER TEN, AB 3043, HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. WE'RE
BEGINNING AS A ONE PERSON
SUBCOMMITTEE. SO I THOUGHT I HAD
ONE OTHER MEMBER, BUT PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AB 310 WILL IMPROVE PATIENT
OUTCOMES AT CALIFORNIA STATE
HOSPITALS BY GATHERING DATA TO
INFORM FUTURE POLICIES THAT WILL
INCREASE THE TRUST AND QUALITY
OF CARE BETWEEN PATIENTS AND
THEIR PHYSICIANS. ASSEMBLY BILL
310 REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS TO SUBMIT A
REPORT BY JANUARY 31ST OF 2026
TO THE LEGISLATURE ON THE AMOUNT
BUDGETED AND EXPENDED FOR CIVIL
SERVICE. PSYCHIATRIST AND
CONTRACT PSYCHIATRIST IN THE
STATE. THIS REPORT WILL INFORM
FUTURE POLICIES THAT IMPROVE
PATIENT CARE AND WILL ADVANCE
CIVIL SERVICE PSYCHIATRY AT
CALIFORNIA STATE HOSPITALS, 90%
OF THE PATIENTS ARE FORENSIC
PSYCHIATRIC PATIENTS WHO WERE
INVOLVED IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. THESE PATIENTS ARE SOME
OF THE MOST COMPLEX PATIENTS WHO
LIVE WITH SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS.
WHILE THE WORK AT THE STATE
HOSPITALS IS DEMANDING,
CONTRACTING CLINICAL CARE
JEOPARDIZES PATIENT HEALTH
OUTCOMES. IT REQUIRES PATIENTS
TO CONSTANTLY ADJUST TO NEW
PROVIDERS AND IT COSTS THE STATE
SIGNIFICANT SETBACKS. THE STATE
MUST MAKE EFFORTS TO HIRE,
UTILIZE AND RETAIN ITS CIVIL
SERVICE EMPLOYEES BEFORE
PIVOTING TO THE USE OF
CONTRACTORS IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL 310 TODAY IS
GEORGE OSBORNE, CONTRACT
ADVOCATE WITH UAPD AND JANICE
O'MALLEY. LEGISLATIVE AND
POLITICAL ACTION REPRESENTATIVE
WITH AFSCME. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. I THOUGHT
HE WAS STILL HERE. THE STAFF
ANALYSIS DID A GOOD JOB RELATING
THE LEGISLATIVE HISTORY OF AB
310 AND ESTABLISHING A PHYSICIAN
REGISTRY AND POTENTIALLY SAVING
THE STATE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
EXPENSIVE CONTRACTORS, OVER TEN
YEARS AGO, LA COUNTY AND UAPD
ENTERED INTO A PARTNERSHIP
WHEREIN A PHYSICIAN REGISTRY WAS
CREATED SO THAT IN-HOUSE
PHYSICIANS, IN-HOUSE
PSYCHIATRISTS, ESPECIALLY, COULD
UTILIZE THE REGISTRY FOR EXTRA
HOURS. THEY WOULD GET EXTRA PAY,
AND THE STATE COULD THE COUNTY
COULD THEN REDUCE THE USE OF
CONTRACTORS, OVER THAT STARTED
OVER TEN YEARS AGO, EVERY YEAR
SINCE THEY'VE SAVED OVER $1
MILLION ON AVERAGE, THE VACANCY
RATE IS PRACTICALLY ZERO NOW IN
THE COUNTY HOSPITALS. AND
THEY'RE NOT USING ANY
CONTRACTORS. AND WE THINK THAT'S
FULLY TO THE CREDIT OF THE
REGISTRY, THE REQUIREMENTS OF AB
310 WILL BE TELLING TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THE PHYSICIAN REGISTRY
THAT THE STATE AND THE AND UAPD
AGREED TO AT THEIR LAST SESSION
AT THE TABLE, ESPECIALLY AND
SINCE THE REGISTRY AS, AS
OUTLINED IN THE MOU IS TOTALLY
AT MANAGEMENT DISCRETION RATHER
THAN THE FRONT LINE PHYSICIANS.
SO AB 310 WILL GIVE US THE DATA
TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THE
SYSTEM IS WORKING AS IT'S
DESCRIBED IN OUR MOU, OR IF IT
NEEDS TWEAKING AND WHERE IT
NEEDS TWEAKING. IT'S A REALLY
SIMPLE BILL, AND WE WOULD URGE
YOUR AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SIR, AFSCME IS A
PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF AB 310, AND
WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
CONTINUED SUPPORT AND HELP HER
AND BOLSTER OUR MEDICAL DOCTORS
IN THE STATE, AND STATE PUBLIC
SERVICE AFSCME, IN COLLABORATION
WITH OUR AFFILIATE UAPD, HAVE
BEEN BEATING THE DRUM FOR
DECADES ON THE NEED TO ADDRESS
THE CRISIS IN RETENTION AND
RECRUITMENT OF THIS ESSENTIAL
WORKFORCE. THIS YEAR, WE'VE
WORKED WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOWENTHAL ON AN AUDIT OF OUR
STATE HOSPITALS, CDCR AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TO TAKE A HOLISTIC LOOK
AT SOME OF OUR FACILITIES.
OVERRELIANCE ON, CONTRACTING OUT
PUBLIC SECTOR JOBS. AND LET'S
TALK ABOUT THE BOTTOM LINE HERE.
OUTSOURCING MEDICAL SERVICES TO
PRIVATE VENDORS. IT MIGHT SEEM
LIKE A QUICK FIX. TO ADDRESS
THESE VACANCY ISSUES, BUT IT
OFTEN ENDS UP COSTING TAXPAYERS
MORE IN THE LONG RUN. PRIVATIZED
CONTRACTS OFTEN COME WITH
INFLATED SERVICE FEES.
ADMINISTRATIVE OVERHEAD, A LACK
OF TRANSPARENCY THAT CAN LEAD TO
WASTE, FRAUD AND ABUSE. BUT THE
COST ISN'T JUST FINANCIAL, IT'S
ALSO HUMAN. WHEN HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ARE OUTSOURCED, OUR
MEMBERS FACE PRECARIOUS
EMPLOYMENT CONDITIONS, LOWER
WAGES, REDUCED BENEFITS AND
LIMITED JOB SECURITY. THIS NOT
ONLY UNDERMINES THE MORALE AND
WELL-BEING OF OUR HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS, BUT ALSO
EXACERBATES TURNOVER RATES AND
STAFFING SHORTAGES, ULTIMATELY
IMPACTING THE QUALITY OF CARE TO
THE INDIVIDUALS UNDER THEIR CARE.
MOREOVER, PRIVATIZED CONTRACTS
OFTEN PRIORITIZE PROFIT OVER
PATIENT CARE, LEADING TO
SUBSTANDARD MEDICAL PRACTICES.
TREATMENT DELAYS, AND COMPROMISE
OUTCOMES FOR PATIENTS. WE HOPE
THAT AB 310 CAN HELP PROVIDE US
WITH THE NECESSARY INFORMATION
TO START ENGAGING IN SERIOUS
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AGENCY,
TO DEVELOP A PLAN TO SUPPORT THE
RETENTION AND RECRUITMENT OF
MEDICAL DOCTORS IN THE STATE.
SERVICE WOULD THAT WE WOULD
APPRECIATE MY VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL, PLEASE STEP
FORWARD AND STATE YOUR NAME,
ORGANIZATION, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. OKAY. SEEING NONE, IS
THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL? OPPOSITION WITNESSES?
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ON THE BILL? SEEING
NONE. WELL MUCH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE PRESENTATION TODAY.
WE DO NOT OBVIOUSLY HAVE A
SUBCOMMITTEE EVEN, BUT WE WILL
HOLD THIS BILL ON CALL AND WE'LL
TAKE IT UP WHEN THE MEMBERS
ARRIVE. AND WE HAVE A COHEN. OH,
I'M SORRY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT. TRUST IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT THINGS BETWEEN A
PATIENT AND THEIR PROVIDER. WHEN
WE'RE CONTRACTING OUT THESE
SERVICES, WE'RE OFTENTIMES NOT
ABLE TO HAVE THE ESTABLISHED
TRUST THAT WE CAN GET FROM THOSE
WHO ARE EMPLOYED BY THE COUNTY
OR THE STATE. I RESPECTFULLY
WILL ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE, AS I
BELIEVE THIS WILL ULTIMATELY
LEAD TOWARDS BETTER PATIENT
OUTCOMES AND BETTER ABILITY FOR
US TO RETAIN THE QUALIFIED STAFF
WHO ARE WORKING AT THOSE STATE
HOSPITALS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ASK WHEN YOU HAVE A
QUORUM. I WILL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
OKAY. ANY AUTHORS WHO ARE
PRESENTING BILLS FOR LABOR,
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT, PLEASE COME TO ROOM
1100. WE ARE READY WHEN YOU ARE.
ALL RIGHT. SO WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE A SLIGHT RECESS AS WE WAIT
FOR OUR PRESENTERS AND SOME OF
OUR MEMBERS HERE. THE COMMITTEE
TO COME INTO THE HEARING ROOM.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IS THERE IS
EVERY COMMITTEE MEETING RIGHT
NOW AT 9:00 AT THE SAME TIME,
AND SO THIS IS GOING TO BE A
LITTLE BIT OF A CHESS GAME AS
PEOPLE COME IN AND COME OUT OF
THE BOARD. SO WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE, A, I'M GOING TO SAY A FIVE
MINUTE RECESS, SEE WHO COMES IN,
AND THEN WE'LL RECONVENE THE
COMMITTEE. AT THAT TIME. THANK
YOU.
OKAY. WE ARE BACK. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON FOR
JOINING US. WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
TO FILE ITEM AB 2494. PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. AND
SENATOR, I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH MY STAFF ON THIS
BILL. AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. AB 2494
WOULD REQUIRE EMPLOYERS TO
PROVIDE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
BEEN TERMINATED OR HAVE
EXPERIENCED A REDUCTION OF THEIR
WORK HOURS WITH A NOTICE ON
THEIR ELIGIBILITY FOR HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE UNDER COBRA, IF A
PERSON IS FIRED FROM THEIR JOB
OR THEIR WORK HOURS ARE REDUCED,
THEY CAN BE AT RISK OF LOSING
THEIR HEALTH CARE INSURANCE AND
THEY MAY NOT EVEN KNOW IT. THESE
CALIFORNIANS MUST WAIT 14 DAYS
BEFORE RECEIVING A NOTIFICATION
FROM THEIR HEALTH PLAN, AND CAN
EVEN BE AT RISK OF LOSING IT IF
THEIR NOTICE IS LOST OR DELAYED
IN THE MAIL. THE IMPACTED
INDIVIDUAL AND THEIR FAMILY CAN
MISS THE DEADLINE TO OPT IN TO
THESE BENEFITS. THIS BILL WOULD
ENSURE THAT THESE EMPLOYEES ARE
EQUIPPED WITH THE INFORMATION
THEY NEED TO PREVENT A
DISRUPTION IN THEIR HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. I DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES. IT'S JUST ME. IT'S AN
AUTHOR SPONSORED BILL, SO
WONDERFUL. WELL, THANK YOU FOR
THAT PRESENTATION. ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL, PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
STATE YOUR NAME, CHRISTINE
SMITH. HEALTH, ACCESS AND
SUPPORT. YOU ANYONE ELSE? Ã
SEEING NO MORE SUPPORT. LET'S
MOVE TO OPPOSITION. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL, PLEASE
STEP FORWARD. NAME, AFFILIATION
AND POSITION. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATOR. WE HAVE
A CONCERNS POSITION. DOROTHY
JOHNSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS, WE'VE REALLY
APPRECIATED THE DIALOG WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE OVER THE LAST
MONTH OR SO, TRYING TO GET TO
THE HEART OF THE ISSUE. I
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE TERMS,
SOME OF THE PROCESSES, AND WE
ALSO REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT REALLY
SPEAKS TO THE QUESTION. WE'RE
REALLY HOPING TO ANSWER, WHICH
IS WHAT ARE WE SOLVING FOR HERE,
I THINK IN THE AUTHOR'S
STATEMENT THAT'S PROVIDED IN THE
ANALYSIS, THERE'S A LITTLE BIT
OF A MISCONCEPTION. AN EMPLOYEE
DOES NOT LOSE COVERAGE WHEN THEY
ARE TERMINATED. YOU HAVE
BASICALLY UP TO FIVE MONTHS IF
YOU COMPRESS ALL OF THE
NOTIFICATION TIME FRAMES BETWEEN
THE EMPLOYER TO THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR, TO THE
INDIVIDUAL, AND THEN FOR WHEN
THE INDIVIDUAL CAN START
PROVIDING PAYMENTS, SO AS YOU
KNOW, ACTS AS A SCHOOL EMPLOYER,
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE OUR
EMPLOYEES HAVE ALL THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED ABOUT
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE WHILE
THEY'RE CURRENTLY EMPLOYED. AND
FOLLOWING TERMINATION, WHICH
COULD BE AT THE ACTION OF THE
EMPLOYEE OR THE EMPLOYER. SO
I'LL LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE CONVERSATION TO FIND A REAL
SOLUTION TO THE POSSIBLE PROBLEM
THAT THIS BILL MIGHT BE TRYING
TO ADDRESS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SEEING NO OTHER OPPOSITION,
I WILL ASK MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I WOULD, SO THE WAY I
GOT THIS BILL IDEA IS, THERE WAS
A CONSTITUENT IN MY DISTRICT WHO
WORKED FOR A LARGE RETAIL CHAIN,
AND THIS PERSON WAS TERMINATED,
AND THEY HAD A MAMMOGRAM THE
FOLLOWING WEEK WHEN THEY WENT TO
CONFIRM THEIR APPOINTMENT, THEY
WERE TOLD THEY NO LONGER HAD
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE BECAUSE THE
DAY THEY WERE TERMINATED, THEY
HAD TO ACTUALLY CALL THEIR
INSURANCE COMPANY AND START SOME
PROCEDURES. SO I'M JUST TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE EMPLOYEE
KNOWS WHAT THEY NEED TO DO.
THEY'RE NOTIFIED, SO THE
COVERAGE CAN CONTINUE. THAT'S
ALL. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND WE WILL HOLD THIS BILL
WHEN WE HAVE A FULL, FORUM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE HAVE, NEXT
FILE ITEM IS AB 2872. ARE YOU
YOU'RE PRESENTING THAT AS WELL?
YES OKAY. AB 2872 WOULD, HELP TO
PROVIDE A NEEDED PAY INCREASE
FOR INVESTIGATORS AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. THE PAY INEQUITY
BETWEEN CDI AND OTHER DIVISIONS
HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED AS A MAJOR
FACTOR IMPACTING RETENTION OF
SWORN OFFICERS AT CDI, DUE TO
THE IMPORTANCE AND COMPLEXITY OF
INSURANCE FRAUD CASES. IT'S
VITAL THAT WE SEEK A COMPARABLE
WAGE TO SUPPORT THE STAFFING OF
THESE PUBLIC SAFETY POSITIONS
WITH EXPERIENCED INVESTIGATORS
HERE TO SPEAK MORE ABOUT THE
NEED FOR THIS BILL IS DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER ERIC CHARLICK AND
DEPUTY CHIEF FELICIA LIEB FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE, GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
SMALLWOOD, RIVAS. VICE CHAIR
WILK MEMBER, MY NAME IS ERIC
TRULOCK. I'M THE DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER OF THE ENFORCEMENT
BRANCH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. AND I'M
HERE TODAY TO AS WELL DISCUSS AB
2872, AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON, INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA IS
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL TO
SUPPORT THE CRITICAL WORK OF OUR
DEPARTMENT'S FRAUD DETECTIVES IN
PROTECTING PUBLIC SAFETY. AB
2872 DOES TWO THINGS. IT ENSURES
PAY PARITY FOR CDI SWORN PEACE
OFFICER FRAUD INVESTIGATORS
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER SWORN
PEACE OFFICERS PERFORMING
SIMILAR WORK WITHIN THE SAME
STATE BARGAINING UNIT NUMBER
SEVEN. IT ALSO ENABLES CDI TO
ADDRESS CRITICAL RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION RETENTION ISSUES FOR
FRAUD INVESTIGATORS. I WANT TO
MAKE IT CLEAR AB 2872 WILL HAVE
MINIMAL OR NO IMPACT ON THE
STATE BUDGET AS CDI IS A
SPECIALLY FUNDED AGENCY, WE ARE
FUNDED BY THE FEES WE COLLECT
THROUGH OUR ENFORCEMENT OF
INSURANCE LAW. OUR DEPARTMENT
CURRENTLY EMPLOYS ABOUT 200
SWORN PEACE OFFICERS TO DETECT,
INVESTIGATE AND RESPOND TO
INSURANCE FRAUD STATEWIDE.
HOWEVER, CURRENT PAY INEQUITIES
AMONG INVESTIGATOR INVESTIGATOR
CLASSIFICATIONS HAVE MADE IT
HARDER FOR US TO RETAIN
EXPERIENCED AND, FRAUD.
INVESTIGATORS RECRUIT, RETAIN
AND RECRUIT EXPERIENCED FRAUD
INVESTIGATORS. AS A RESULT, THE
DEPARTMENT'S CURRENT VACANCY
RATE FOR THIS CLASSIFICATION
SITS ABOVE 33. THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND IS PUTTING SOME
OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS AT RISK, INCLUDING
OUR SENIORS AND OUR WORKERS.
THAT IS WHY I'M HERE TODAY.
THESE INVESTIGATORS ARE IN THE
SAME BARGAINING BARGAINING UNIT
AS CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE SWORN INVESTIGATORS. BUT
THEY EARNED 21% LESS THAN THEIR
COLLEAGUES. THIS HAS BEEN AN
ONGOING PROBLEM AT OUR
DEPARTMENT FOR ALMOST TWO
DECADES. THE INSURANCE MARKET IN
CALIFORNIA IS THE SECOND LARGEST
IN THE WORLD, AND INSURANCE
FRAUD CRIMES COSTS CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES AND FAMILIES BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS EACH YEAR. IN FACT,
THE COALITION AGAINST INSURANCE
FRAUD ESTIMATES THERE'S OVER $17
BILLION OF ECONOMIC LOSS TO
CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR DUE TO
INSURANCE FRAUD. THE REALITY IS,
OUR PEACE OFFICERS ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERPAID AND
STRETCHED THIN AND BECAUSE OF
THIS, THEY CONTINUE TO FACE
CRITICAL SHORTAGES THAT PUT
PURSUING MANY CASES IN PERIL.
THE CDI FRAUD DIVISION RECEIVES
OVER 22,000 SUSPECTED FRAUD
REFERRALS EACH YEAR,
REPRESENTING OVER $600 MILLION
IN POTENTIAL LOSS. THIS
SIGNIFICANT GAP IN PAY POSES
SERIOUS CHALLENGES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNITY, THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY AND CONSUMERS
STATEWIDE, AB 2872 IS CRITICAL
TO HELPING OUR DEPARTMENT. YOUR
TIME IS. OH, SORRY. CAN YOU JUST
BRING IT TO A CLOSE? YEAH. THIS
IS THE LAST, LAST. YES. IT'S
CRITICAL TO HELPING OUR
DEPARTMENT PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
AND PREVENT ECONOMIC LOSS
THROUGH THE DETECTION,
INVESTIGATION AND PROSECUTION OF
INSURANCE FRAUD OFFENDERS. AND
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA, I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR. COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
MY NAME IS FELICIA LIEBE. I'M A
DEPUTY CHIEF OUT OF THE
SACRAMENTO ENFORCEMENT BRANCH
HEADQUARTERS. WE ARE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS, MANY OF OUR INVESTIGATORS
HAVE LEFT CDI FOR DOJ AND
CURRENTLY WE ARE AWARE OF SIX
OTHERS THAT ARE EITHER IN THE
BACKGROUND PROCESS OR WHO HAVE
RECENTLY INTERVIEWED FOR
POSITIONS WITH DOJ. AND JUST
LAST WEEK, WE WERE NOTIFIED. TWO
INVESTIGATORS HAVE NEGOTIATED
START DATES WITH DOJ FOR LATER
THIS MONTH. ONE OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAS BEEN WITH US FOR
24 YEARS. THIS IS A TOUGH
DECISION FOR HER BECAUSE SHE'S
GROWN UP WITH THE AGENCY AND
SHE'S ONE OF OUR MOST SKILLED
INVESTIGATORS ASSIGNED TO A TASK
FORCE THAT INVESTIGATES WORKER'S
COMPENSATION FRAUD TO INCLUDE
WAGE THEFT, LABOR TRAFFICKING
AND DISSUASION OF MEDICAL
TREATMENT FOR INJURED WORKERS.
THIS INVESTIGATOR IS HIGHLY
VALUABLE, HIGHLY RESPECTED AS A
TRAINING OFFICER, AND SHE'S
MENTORED MANY OF THE DETECTIVES,
A LOT OF THEM SITTING BEHIND ME
OVER THE YEARS FOR OUR OFFICES
AND BEING A SINGLE MOM, SHE
CANNOT PASS UP A 21% PAY
INCREASE. SHE HAS TO PROVIDE FOR
HERSELF AND HER FINANCIAL FUTURE
OF HER FAMILY. SO WE NEED TO
RETAIN OUR EXPERIENCED
INVESTIGATORS. THESE ARE
INVESTIGATORS WHO TRAIN CHP
OFFICERS ON HOW TO IDENTIFY
STAGE COLLISIONS. THEY ROLL OUT
TO THE STAGE COLLISIONS,
INVESTIGATE. WE JUST HAD A
RECENT CASE WHERE WE IDENTIFIED
20 ADDITIONAL STAGE COLLISIONS
BY INDIVIDUALS INVESTIGATED BY
OUR AGENCY, OUR EXPERIENCED
INVESTIGATORS ALSO LOOK AT THE
SOBER LIVING TREATMENT
FACILITIES THAT HAVE ZERO REGARD
TO PATIENT CARE AND ARE
UTILIZING THESE INDIVIDUALS AND
TREATING THEM, BUT NOT REALLY
TREATING THEM USING THE BENEFITS.
AND WHEN THAT POLICY RUNS OUT,
THEY'RE KICKING THEM OUT ON THE
STREETS AND MAKING THEM SUFFER
WITH THEIR ADDICTION. OUR
EXPERIENCE INVESTIGATORS ALSO,
THEY'RE VALUABLE TO OUR
SUCCESSION PLANNING. OKAY. SO
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS IS A VICIOUS
CYCLE. WE NEED TO RETAIN OUR
INVESTIGATORS. AND WE ARE HOPING
AB 2872 PUTS A MORE PERMANENT
FIX TO BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN THAT
EQUITY. AND SO WE CAN RETAIN OUR
INVESTIGATORS WITH OUR AGENCY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
OKAY. ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL,
PLEASE STEP FORWARD. STATE YOUR
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION.
HI, MY NAME IS LEE ADAMSON. I'M
A DETECTIVE SERGEANT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE, SACRAMENTO REGIONAL
OFFICE, AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M DETECTIVE VLADIMIR OLEYNIK
WITH CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE FRAUD DIVISION, AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. ADAM LOOMIS,
A DETECTIVE WITH DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE FRAUD DIVISION AND
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, DETECTIVE GINA
CAMACHO, DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
FRAUD DIVISION. AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. DETECTIVE ADAM
BABITZ, CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. DETECTIVE. DETECTIVE DEVIN
BROWN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE FRAUD
DIVISION. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. GOOD MORNING, CAPTAIN
CHRISTINA SMITH, CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE FRAUD
DIVISION. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CAPTAIN SUSAN BURNS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE FRAUD DIVISION. AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. GOOD MORNING,
DETECTIVE SERGEANT JEAN MARSHALL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE RECRUITMENT AND
BACKGROUND INVESTIGATIONS TEAM
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. I HIGHLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
ALICIA DANIEL, SERGEANT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE FRAUD DIVISION. I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. MORNING,
DETECTIVE SERGEANT MATTHEW
RODGERS, CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE. I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. GOOD MORNING. MARGARET
FELL, DETECTIVE WITH THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
DETECTIVE ADELBERT ARMENTA WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE FRAUD DIVISION. AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, DETECTIVE MITCH
PINGREE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. GOOD MORNING,
DETECTIVE CHRISTINA Â WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE FRAUD DIVISION. AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
MORNING, DETECTIVE. CHRISTINA
MICHELLE, THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. GOOD MORNING,
EVERYONE. DETECTIVE ABIMBOLA,
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE, SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL OFFICE, AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. GOOD MORNING, LANCE
FERRARI, CAPTAIN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL AS WELL. GOOD MORNING,
DANIEL MACIAS, DETECTIVE
SERGEANT, GOLDEN GATE REGIONAL
OFFICE. I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
DETECTIVE MICHELLE GUICHARD WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE, AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. GOOD MORNING, DETECTIVE
JOEL LARA, CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE FRAUD DIVISION. I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. GOOD MORNING.
JOHN BARLOW. SERGEANT,
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, JANELLE
PEREZ, DETECTIVE SERGEANT
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE, AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. GOOD MORNING, NELSON
RODRIGUEZ, DETECTIVE SERGEANT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. MORNING, DETECTIVE NIELSEN
HUESO, CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MORNING, AARON GILL, DETECTIVE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. GOOD MORNING, TAD BATEMAN,
DETECTIVE, CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. GOOD MORNING. ERIC
WILLIAMS, DEPUTY CHIEF,
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. OKAY WELL,
ANYONE I THINK THAT'S IT. ON
SUPPORT ANYONE HERE? WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL,
PLEASE STEP FORWARD AND HAVE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS. SHANE LEVINE, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATION, WHICH IS CSEA
BARGAINING UNIT SEVEN'S,
RECOGNIZED LABOR ORGANIZATION,
SADLY, WE ARE IN A OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION, THE ISSUES OF
PAY AND RETENTION. RATES ACROSS
THE BOARD ARE NOT NEW ISSUES FOR
US. THEY CONTINUE TO BE ISSUES
THAT WE, ARE ALWAYS IN CONSTANT
CONVERSATION WITH CAL HR AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT AND TRYING
TO EFFECTIVELY, COLLECTIVELY
BARGAIN, SO THIS ISN'T ISOLATED
TO SIMPLY CDI, OR ANY NUMBER OF
THE OTHER FOLKS THAT WE
REPRESENT, IT'S A CHALLENGE. SO
LOOK, AGAIN, WE'RE NOT IN
OPPOSED TO INCREASING WAGES. IN
FACT, WE SUBMITTED AMENDMENTS
THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR A WE WOULD
SUPPORT A ONE TIME EQUIVALENCY
PAYMENT TO GET CDI INVESTIGATORS
CAUGHT UP TO DOJ AGAIN, NOBODY'S
OPPOSED TO MORE MONEY. CERTAINLY
THAT'S, ANATHEMA TO WHAT WE
REPRESENT. OR MORE BENEFITS,
IT'S SIMPLY THE WAY THE BILL IS
CRAFTED TO CREATE A PARITY
FORMULA WITH DOJ. WE HAVE TO
OPPOSE THAT, THAT CIRCUMVENTS
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
PROCESS. SO IF THAT WERE
UNSHACKLED AND THIS SIMPLY
BECAME ABOUT CDI, WE WOULD FULLY
SUPPORT THIS INITIATIVE. AND AS
MR. LAIRD, WHO WAS A FORMER
NATURAL, THE NATURAL RESOURCES
SECRETARY, CAN PROBABLY
ILLUMINATE HIS TIME WITH THE
RANGERS. I MEAN, THESE THIS IS A
THIS IS AN ISSUE, WE'RE WELL
AWARE OF IT AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK HARD ON BEHALF
OF OUR MEMBERS, BOTH CDI
INVESTIGATORS, DOJ AGENTS AND
EVERYBODY ELSE, TO CONTINUE TO
WORK HARD FOR BETTER PAY AND
BENEFITS. AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT. BUT RIGHT
NOW, REGRETTABLY, WE'RE IN A
POSITION TO OPPOSE, UNLESS
AMENDED, WITH THAT, WITH THAT
AMENDMENT. SO WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL? PLEASE
STEP FORWARD. STATE YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. Ã
SEEING NONE. WE'RE COMING TO THE
DAIS. ANOTHER LAYER? YES SHE'S
GOING TO CALL ON EVERY OTHER
SENATOR THAT'S HERE, YOU LET ME
SPEAK TO THIS BILL, AND SINCE I
WAS JUST REFERRED TO, I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING IT. AND I THINK
THAT THAT WHAT WAS JUST REFERRED
TO IS. YES, I WAS A CABINET
SECRETARY FOR EIGHT YEARS UNDER
JERRY BROWN. AND YES, THERE WERE
MASSIVE INEQUITIES THROUGHOUT
THE SYSTEM, AND WE ATTEMPTED TO
TAKE THEM ON WHEREVER WE COULD,
WHENEVER WE COULD. AND WITH
REGARD TO THE, EVERYBODY KNOWS
THEM AS GAME WARDENS. THEY'RE
NOW WILDLIFE OFFICERS AND PARK
RANGERS. WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND CHAIR OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE, WE DID A SPECIAL
AUGMENTATION IN THE BUDGET JUST
FOR THOSE TWO UNITS AND ALLOWED
AN ADJUSTMENT UP BECAUSE, THEY
WERE THEY COULDN'T RECRUIT. THEY
WERE LOSING PEOPLE. IT WAS
AFFECTING OUR ABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT, THE PROGRAMS. I THINK
THE SAME THING IS TRUE HERE. THE
TESTIMONY MENTIONED IT. AND SO I
THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE APPROVE THIS AND MAKE THE
POINT. BUT I ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE OPPOSITION,
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T MEAN WE DON'T
HAVE TO ATTACK AND ADDRESS
ISSUES THAT EXIST ACROSS THE
UNIT AND ACROSS STATE
GOVERNMENT, BECAUSE WITH THE
INFLATION, THE COST OF LIVING,
WE ARE HAVING TROUBLE, FILLING
POSITIONS AND, AND A LIGHTER
MOMENT, I WOULD JUST SAY IF
THERE WAS EVER A MORNING TO, TO
COMMIT INSURANCE FRAUD THIS
MIGHT BE IT BECAUSE EVERYBODY'S
HERE, AND NOT THERE, EVEN THOUGH
I KNOW THAT'S A LONG TERM ISSUE.
SO I APPRECIATE THE DIFFERENCES,
BUT I THINK IT'S I SALUTE THE
AUTHOR FOR HIGHLIGHTING THIS,
AND WE'LL SUPPORT THE BILL WHEN
IT COMES TO A VOTE, BUT WILL NOT
LOSE SIGHT OF ALL THE OTHER
THINGS THAT WE HAVE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR LAIRD. AND, YOU KNOW, I
ALSO WANTED TO SAY THAT I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY, I
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGE HERE.
AND BUT I UNDERSTAND ALSO PAY
EQUITY AND HOW DIFFICULT IT IS,
WHEN YOU'RE DOING SAME WORK,
VERY SIMILAR WORK, AND NOT BEING
PAID AND COMPENSATED AND REALLY
APPRECIATED THE TESTIMONY OF THE
WITNESS. YOU KNOW, I DO KNOW
THAT GENERALLY COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING IS HOW WE RESOLVE PAY
ISSUES. THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
UNIONS. THAT'S WHY WE BELIEVE IN
UNIONS. THAT'S WHY I BELIEVE IN
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT. SOMETIMES, IN THIS
ROLE, WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
WAYS TO DEVELOP SOLUTIONS THAT
ACTUALLY MAY END UP
STRENGTHENING OUR BARGAINING
UNITS. AND I WANT TO SAY MY
COMMITMENT TO WORKERS OF THE
STATE TO ALWAYS WORK WITH OUR
UNIONS, TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
PAYING OUR STAFF WHAT THEY
DESERVE. AND ALSO ADDRESSING THE
COMPETITION AND VACANCIES THAT
WE STRUGGLE WITH BECAUSE WE ARE
COMPETING WITH SO MANY FORCES
OUT THERE FOR OUR TALENT. AND
SO, YOU KNOW, THIS BILL WILL
HELP THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
FULFILL THAT MISSION TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS FROM FRAUD BY
HAVING A STAFF THAT FEELS
RESPECTED AND CAN BE RETAINED
BECAUSE THEY HAVE STRONGER
STANDARDS. SO WE WILL PUT THIS
BILL ON CALL. WAIT FOR US TO GET
OUR QUORUM, AND THEN WE'LL WORK
TO TAKE OUR VOTES THEN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE BEFORE WE WANT TO SAY I
APPRECIATE BOTH OF YOUR
COMMENTS, AND, YOU KNOW, IT
REALLY IS AN HONOR TO BRING
FORWARD THIS BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR, HOW
HAVE YOU BEEN? I AM GOING TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 1137 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER REGGIE
JONES. SAWYER AND I WOULD BEGIN
BY SAYING THAT ON HIS BEHALF, I
WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS AND THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL. THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE FAIRNESS IN STATE
EMPLOYMENT BY PROVIDING
EQUITABLE BENEFITS TO STATE
SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS. A
CURRENTLY EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES,
SUCH AS STATE SUPERVISORS AND
MANAGERS, DO NOT HAVE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING RIGHTS AND ARE ONLY
ABLE TO ACCESS BETTER BENEFITS
THROUGH LEGISLATION. THIS BILL
WILL INCREASE PARITY BY
REQUIRING THAT THE STATE
SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS RECEIVE
NOTIFICATION WHEN DENIED A MERIT
SALARY ADJUSTMENT, AND PROVIDE
COMPENSATION FOR TIME WORKED ON
PREMIUM HOLIDAYS. IT WILL
PROMOTE EQUITY IN THE WORKPLACE
FOR HUNDREDS OF STATE EMPLOYEES.
WITH ME IS TED TOPPIN, ON BEHALF
OF THE BILL'S SPONSOR, THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA STATE
SUPERVISORS, AND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME, HOPEFULLY IN
OUR NATURAL LIFE, SOMETIME WHEN
THERE'S A QUORUM, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE.
THANK YOU, GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. IT'S, TED
THOMPSON FOR ACCESS. LET ME
FIRST THANK, MR. LAIRD FOR
STEPPING UP AND STEPPING IN AND
DOING A FABULOUS PRESENTATION.
WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE IT. I
WOULD BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE, ASSEMBLYMAN
JONES-SAWYER, FOR I THANK HIM
FOR INTRODUCING THE BILL. HE HAS
BEEN A CHAMPION FOR STATE
SUPERVISORS AND ALL SUPERVISORS
AND MANAGERS IN PUBLIC SERVICE
THROUGHOUT HIS TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE, AND I JUST WANTED
TO ACKNOWLEDGE IT BECAUSE IT'S
MUCH APPRECIATED, THIS BILL IS
ABOUT FUNDAMENTAL FAIRNESS AND
EQUITY FOR STATE SUPERVISORS AND
MANAGERS. IF WE WANT PEOPLE TO
STEP UP, MANAGE OTHER EMPLOYEES,
MANAGE STATE DEPARTMENTS AND
PROGRAMS, YOU GOT TO TREAT THEM
EQUITABLY. AND THIS BILL SIMPLY
PROVIDES TO THEM, THE SAME
BENEFITS THAT THEIR RANK AND
FILE COLLEAGUES HAVE ACHIEVED
THROUGH COLLECTIVE BARGAINING,
WE WOULD URGE YOUR AYE VOTE AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT MIGHT ARISE. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE HERE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL?
PLEASE STEP FORWARD. OKAY I
GUESS I COULD OFFICIALLY WITH MY
PROXY, BUT, THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT
AND CAPS UAW. SO THANK YOU ALL.
DUTY THANK YOU. ANYONE SPEAKING
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL?
SEEING NONE, I THINK THANK YOU
SO MUCH, SENATOR LAIRD, FOR THAT
PRESENTATION. AND, YOU KNOW, I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY WITH THE ACCEPTANCE OF THE
AMENDMENTS, WE WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR, YOU KNOW, LOOKING AT THOSE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT THE BILL DOES RAISE
BENEFITS FOR EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES,
WE KNOW THAT, WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR RANK AND FILE, ARE
ABLE TO DRAW DOWN ON THOSE
EXISTING BENEFITS AND WE
APPRECIATE IT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? YES. I APPRECIATE THE
VERY ROBUST DISCUSSION. AND AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME, WHEN
REQUESTED, I VOTE WE WILL TAKE
IT UP AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
WE HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU.
OKAY. THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
LABOR, PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT, AND
RETIREMENT WILL TAKE A BRIEF
RECESS. WE ARE CALLING ALL
AUTHORS, IN THE MEANTIME,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAVO, ORTEGA.
MCKENNA FEEL FREE TO COME ON
DOWN SO WE CAN WRAP UP THIS
SESSION, UNTIL THEN, WE WILL
HAVE A FIVE MINUTE RECESS.
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO COME BACK
FROM OUR VERY BRIEF RECESS.
SINCE WE HAVE A QUORUM, WE DON'T
WANT IT TO SLIP THROUGH OUR
FINGERS. SO. LET'S SEE,
COMMITTEE ASSISTANT. DO YOU WANT
TO CALL THE ROLL? ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS HERE. WILK.
CORTEZ CORTEZ HERE. DURAZO.
LAIRD. LAIRD HERE. AND MADAM
CHAIR, I AM REALLY MOVED. SO I
WOULD MOVE THE CONSENT AGENDA.
WELL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LET'S
CALL THE ROLL. FOR TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS FIVE ITEMS.
NUMBER THREE AND FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE. THAT'S AB 2134 AND
AB 2573 ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WILK CORTEZ. CORTEZ I
DURAZO. LAIRD I. LAIRD I. OKAY.
WE HAVE A VOTE OF 3 TO 0 ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AND IT IS ON
CALL. TURNING IT, WE HAVE FOUR,
BILLS THAT WE HEARD AND WE COULD
CATCH UP IF IT'S OKAY WITH YOU,
THEN I WOULD MOVE, FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE, AB 310 BY DOCTOR
ARAMBULA. YOU HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR LAIRD. ASSISTANT. CALL
THE ROLL ON FILE. ITEM NUMBER
ONE. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK CORTEZ.
CORTEZ. I DURAZO. LAIRD I. LAIRD
I. OKAY. WE HAVE A VOTE OF 3 TO
0. THAT BILL IS ON CALL. AND,
MADAM CHAIR, I WOULD MOVE FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB 1137 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES. SAWYER A
MOVED BY SENATOR LAIRD ASSISTING
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. Ã.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. I WILK
CORTEZ. ORTEZ I DURAZO LAIRD I.
LAIRD I OKAY, WE HAVE A VOTE OF
3 TO 0. THE BILL IS ON CALL.
MADAM CHAIR, I WOULD MOVE FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR, ASSEMBLY BILL
2494 BY CALDERON. THANK YOU.
ASSISTANT. CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK ORTEZ.
CORTEZ I DURAZO. LAIRD I. LAIRD
I. WE HAVE A VOTE OF 3 TO 0 ON
THAT BILL. THE BILL IS ON CALL.
AND, MADAM CHAIR, I WOULD MOVE,
FINAL ITEM NUMBER FIVE, ASSEMBLY
BILL 2872 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON. THANK YOU. SENATOR
LAIRD. ASSISTANT, CALL THE ROLL
ON. FINAL ITEM NUMBER FIVE. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. I WILK CORTEZ. CORTEZ I
DURAZO. LAIRD I. LAIRD I. OKAY.
WE HAVE A VOTE OF 3 TO 0, AND
THAT BILL IS ON CALL. OKAY. WE
SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA IS IN
THE HOUSE. WE WILL PROCEED. JUST
HAVE A SEAT AND WE'RE READY.
WHEN? WHEN YOU ARE. THAT IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. A B2557.
AND MEMBERS, THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB 2557.
TODAY, I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, WHICH WILL EXCLUDE
ANY CONTRACT FOR SERVICES THAT
ARE UNDER $100,000, IN WHICH THE
WORK IS NOT USUALLY PERFORMED BY
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES. AB 2572557 HAS
BEEN SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED, AND
NOW REALLY IS JUST MAKING SURE
THAT ANY CONTRACTS THAT GO OUT,
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY BY MAKING
SURE THAT THE CONTRACTING OUT
FOR SERVICES ARE, DISPLAYED ON
WEBSITES SO THAT AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND SENATORS AND, YOU
KNOW, IT IS OUR DUTY AND
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE KNOW WHERE OUR RESOURCES ARE
GOING, OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE
GOING, AND THAT WE KNOW WHETHER
OR NOT WE'RE GETTING THE RESULTS
THAT WE WERE TOLD WE WERE GOING
TO GET. THAT IS HOW WE ARE ABLE
TO EVALUATE WHETHER THINGS ARE
WORKING OR NOT. AND SO THIS HAS
JUST BEEN ALWAYS HAS BEEN A
SIMPLE TRANSPARENCY. AND
ACCOUNTABILITY BILL, WITH ME
TESTIFYING IS BRYANT MIRAMONTES
WITH AFSCME CALIFORNIA AND
IVONNE FERNANDEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
LOOK AT THAT. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. YVONNE FERNANDEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION,
A PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF AB 2557,
AS STATED BY THE AUTHOR, WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE WORKED WITH THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF IN DEVELOPING
THE AMENDMENTS FOR THE BILL. AS
STATED, AB 2557 WILL REQUIRE
LOCAL AGENCIES TO POST CONTRACTS
THAT THEY HAVE ENTERED INTO WITH
PRIVATE SERVICE PROVIDERS ON
THEIR WEBSITES BY 2026,
CONTRACTS BETWEEN LOCAL AGENCIES
AND PRIVATE CONTRACTORS WILL
CONTAIN Kò INFORMATION, SUCH AS
THE FINANCIAL EXPENDITURES OF
THE PUBLIC DOLLARS AND THE
DELIVERABLES EXPECTED FROM THE
CONTRACTOR. AB 2557 AIMS AT
INCREASING TRANSPARENCY ON THE
WIDESPREAD PRACTICE OF
CONTRACTING OUT BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, CONTRACTING OUT HAS
LED TO THE DECLINE OF MIDDLE
CLASS CAREER OPPORTUNITIES,
ESPECIALLY FOR WOMEN AND BIPOC
INDIVIDUALS. PREVIOUSLY VIEWED
AS THE BACKBONE OF THE MIDDLE
CLASS, PUBLIC SECTOR, JOBS
PROVIDED COMMUNITY MEMBERS WITH
LONG TERM, SUSTAINABLE
EMPLOYMENT. TODAY MANY SIMPLY DO
NOT HAVE THESE OPPORTUNITIES IN
HOUSE, PUBLIC SECTOR WORKERS
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY SERVICES
FOR COMMUNITIES IN NEED.
COMMUNITIES RELIANT ON
GOVERNMENT SERVICES OFTEN
BENEFIT FROM DIRECT LOCAL AGENCY
SUPPORT CONDUCTED BY WORKERS
TRAINED AND SELECTED THROUGH THE
PUBLIC AGENCY DIRECTLY. THE
CURRENT PROCESS FOR LOCAL OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS APPROVING AND
RE APPROVING CONTRACTS NEEDS
IMPROVEMENT. GIVEN THE FISCAL
ENVIRONMENT, WE ARE IN TODAY,
THERE NEEDS TO. WE NEED TO
ENSURE EVERY DOLLAR IS SPENT
EFFECTIVELY. AB 2557 INCREASES
TRANSPARENCY ON CONTRACTS
BETWEEN, BETWEEN PRIVATE SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
BY REQUIRING CONTRACTS BE MADE
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE. AND FOR
THESE REASONS, WE RESPECTFULLY
URGE AN AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. YOU MAY PROCEED.
MADAM CHAIR, COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BRYANT MIRAMONTEZ WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES,
REPRESENTING OVER 200,000 OF
PUBLIC SERVICE WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA, INCLUDING MANY
CITIES, COUNTIES, SPECIAL
DISTRICTS, WE ARE IN PROUD
CO-SPONSORS OF AB 2557. AND
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL. AND ALSO THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. WE AGREE THAT
CONTRACTORS IN BOTH THE FOR
PROFIT AND NONPROFIT INDUSTRIES
PROVIDE SERVICES TO COMMUNITIES
THAT MANY GOVERNMENTS DON'T,
WON'T, OR SIMPLY CAN'T DO. THE
NATURE OF SUCH EXTERNAL WORK IS
NOT WHAT OUR UNIONS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT. WE ARE
SPECIFICALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SERVICES THAT HAVE BEEN
INCREASINGLY CONTRACTED OUT THAT
ARE CUSTOMARILY PERFORMED BY
PUBLIC WORKERS, LIKE SOCIAL
SERVICES, HEALTH SERVICES,
TRANSPORTATION, TO NAME A FEW.
WHEN LOCAL AGENCIES CONTRACT OUT
WORK THAT COULD AND SHOULD BE
DONE BY PRIVATE PUBLIC SECTOR
WORKERS WITHOUT ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT, THE AFFECTED
WORKFORCE AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC SUFFER. AND I FIRST JUST
WANT TO DISPEL WHAT YOU WILL
HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION TODAY.
YOU WILL HEAR THAT THE MBBA
ALREADY PROHIBITS EMPLOYERS FROM
CONTRACTING OUT FOR COST
SAVINGS. FROM OUR VIEW, THIS IS
SIMPLY NOT TRUE. THE OPPOSITION
MAY BE CONFLATING THE STATE
EMPLOYMENT CONTRACTING
REQUIREMENTS WITH LOCAL
CONTRACTING REQUIREMENTS, WHICH
AREN'T SUBJECT TO SUCH
PROTECTIONS. ADDITIONALLY, YOU
WILL HEAR THAT THESE
REQUIREMENTS WILL LIMIT THE POOL
OF PROVIDERS INTERESTED IN
CONTRACTING WITH LOCAL AGENCIES.
THIS IS ALSO NOT TRUE. THIS BILL
IS SO LIMITED IN NATURE THAT IT
SIMPLY REQUIRES AGENCIES TO
UPLOAD THEIR CONTRACTS, AND
EVENTUALLY INCLUDE ESSENTIAL
INFORMATION IN THEM, IF AND ONLY
IF THOSE CONTRACTS EXCEED
$100,000, PER THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS, AND IF AND ONLY IF
THAT WORK IS CUSTOMARILY
PERFORMED BY PUBLIC SECTOR
WORKERS. FURTHER, YOU WILL ALSO
HEAR THAT THE SCOPE OF SERVICES
IS MUCH TOO BROAD. BUT WITH THE
NEW AMENDMENTS, THIS WILL BE
AGAIN BE VERY LIMITED TO THE
CONTRACTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
PROVIDED BY THE UNIONIZED
WORKFORCE. THIS IS ABOUT
PROTECTING PUBLIC SECTOR WORKERS
AND HOLDING AGENCIES ACCOUNTABLE
FOR BEING MORE TRANSPARENT IN
THEIR CONTRACTS, BY REQUIRING
THEM TO UPLOAD THEM ONLINE AND
INCLUDE JUST REALLY CRITICAL,
IMPORTANT YOU BEGIN TO WRAP UP
YOUR TIME WITH THAT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH, ANYONE
ELSE HERE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL? PLEASE STEP
FORWARD. STATE YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS TERRY BRENNAN
ON BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT, I JUST REMIND YOU THAT
EVERY DIME SPENT ON SALARIES FOR
THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES CURRENTLY
PERFORMING THESE JOBS, INCLUDING
THEIR PENSIONS, IS PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE. WE'D ASK THE SAME FOR
THE CONTRACTORS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND SENATORS DOUG SUBERS, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, CHRIS
MYERS WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THE THINK THAT IS IT FOR
SUPPORT. ANYONE HERE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL?
PLEASE STEP FORWARD. OPPOSITION
WITNESSES HAVE A SEAT. THE
TABLE. YOU BOTH HAVE TWO
MINUTES.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS JOSE VARGAS
WITH UNITED WAYS OF CALIFORNIA,
THE STATE ASSOCIATION FOR OUR
LOCAL UNITED WAYS. HERE IN
RESPECTABLE OPPOSITION. WE
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION THAT
MANY LEADING NONPROFITS HAVE
WITH YOU, MADAM CHAIR, TO SHARE
SOME OF THE MANY CONCERNS THAT
WE CONTINUE TO UPLIFT.
UNFORTUNATELY, OUR CONCERNS HAVE
NOT BEEN ADDRESSED IN THE LATEST
AMENDMENTS. REGRETTABLY, DON'T
MOVE THE NEEDLE. YOU KNOW,
CALIFORNIA IS PART OF A
NONPROFIT CONTRACTING COALITION
WORKING TO STRENGTHEN AND
IMPROVE GOVERNMENT AND NONPROFIT
PARTNERSHIPS AS CONVEYED IN A
LETTER SIGNED BY LEADERS OF MORE
THAN 200 NONPROFITS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. WE URGE YOUR NO VOTE
TO AVOID SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE
IMPACTS THAT WOULD RESULT FROM
THIS BILL'S ENACTMENT, INCLUDING
THE POTENTIAL DISRUPTION OF
SERVICE DELIVERY FOR COUNTLESS
CALIFORNIANS. I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT DESPITE THE
ISSUES WITH THE BILL, OUR
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR AND UNIONS IS
RICH AND FULL OF JOINT
VICTORIES. THIS SCALES ALL THE
WAY BACK FROM THE EXPANSION OF
SOCIAL PROGRAMS AND LABOR RIGHTS
UNDER PRESIDENT ROOSEVELT'S NEW
DEAL POLICIES. PRESIDENT LYNDON
B JOHNSON'S WAR ON POVERTY,
WHICH BROUGHT UNIONS AND
NONPROFITS TOGETHER TO TACKLE
ISSUES OF ECONOMIC INEQUALITY
AND POVERTY, AND SO MUCH MORE.
WE'RE PROUD TO HAVE SUPPORTED
SENATOR LENO'S SUCCESSFUL EFFORT
TO INCREASE CALIFORNIA'S MINIMUM
WAGE, AND WILL CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT SUCH MEASURES. IN SHORT,
WE ARE EMBEDDED IN THE DNA OF
PUBLIC SERVICES AND SOCIAL
PROGRAMS. NONPROFITS ARE
CONSISTENTLY RELIED UPON BY THE
GOVERNMENT PRECISELY BECAUSE
WE'RE DEEPLY CONNECTED TO
COMMUNITIES AND CAN PROVIDE
SPECIALIZED QUALITY, COST
EFFECTIVE SERVICES THAT MATCH
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF EACH
COMMUNITY. GOVERNMENTS ARE ABLE
TO LEVERAGE THIS DEEPLY ROOTED
TRUST TO EXPAND THEIR REACH AND
ENSURE THE NEEDS OF CITIZENS ARE
ROBUSTLY MET. OUR PRIMARY
CONCERN WITH AB 2557 REVOLVES
AROUND HOW THE BILL WOULDN'T
ACTUALLY IMPROVE SERVICES OR
SERVICE DELIVERY. FOR STARTERS,
THE BILL ENCOMPASSES A WIDE AND
UNCLEAR SCOPE OF SERVICES AND
JOB FUNCTIONS, WHILE ALSO
INCLUDING TERMS AND REQUIREMENTS
THAT DON'T FIT THE WAY THAT
NONPROFITS AND FOR PROFIT
COMPANIES, ESPECIALLY SMALL
ORGANIZATIONS, ARE ORGANIZED FOR
EXAMPLE, THE USE OF JOB CATEGORY
AND JOB CLASSIFICATION IN THE
BILL LANGUAGE. THIS IS
PARTICULARLY WORRYING FOR OUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE ONLY THING
THIS BILL WOULD DO WITH 100%
CERTAINTY IS DRIVE UP
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THIS WOULD RESULT
IN FEWER CONTRACTS AND THUS A
REDUCTION OF SERVICES FOR
COMMUNITIES. LASTLY, WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENT TO EXEMPT CONTRACTS
THAT ARE LESS THAN $100,000,
WE'D BE REMISS IF WE DIDN'T
MENTION THAT THIS WOULDN'T EVEN
COVER SINGLE FULL TIME POSITION
WITH BENEFITS. AS SUCH, THIS
CHANGE WOULD MAKE NO MEANINGFUL
DIFFERENCE. I THINK WE ALL WANT
THE SAME THING ROBUST EMPLOYMENT
AND THE BETTERMENT OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. BY PROVIDING THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF SERVICES WE
CAN. THIS BILL HELPS NEITHER.
FOR THESE REASONS, WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR SMALLWOOD AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I'M LAKE COUNTY
SUPERVISOR EDDIE CRANDALL, AND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION OF AB
2557. THERE ARE MORE THAN 4800
LOCAL AGENCIES IN THE STATE.
MOST OF WHICH RELY AT LEAST IN
PART ON CONTRACTORS TO PROVIDE A
VARIETY OF LOCAL PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THAT, GIVEN OUR CURRENT
PUBLIC SECTOR WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES, WOULD BE DIFFICULT TO
PROVIDE WITHOUT THEIR CAPABLE
ASSISTANCE, MAKE NO MISTAKES. AB
2557 WILL BE COSTLY TO IMPLEMENT
AT A TIME WHEN THE STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES ARE FACING
SIGNIFICANT FISCAL CHALLENGES,
IT IS DIFFICULT TO FATHOM THAT
THE EXTENSIVE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE BILL ARE WORTH THE
INVESTMENT OF SCARCE PUBLIC
RESOURCES. WHILE RECENT
AMENDMENTS REMOVE THE OBLIGATION
FOR REPORTING BY CONTRACTORS
DIRECTLY. AB 2557 TAKES MOST OF
THOSE SAME REQUIREMENTS AND
REQUIRES LOCAL AGENCIES TO PUT
THEM IN THE CONTRACTUAL
AGREEMENT. NEW AMENDMENTS ALSO
REMOVE A PRIOR EXEMPTION FOR
CONTRACTS BETWEEN GOVERNMENT,
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES, IMPOSING
REDUNDANCY FOR BOTH STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CONTRACTING
PARTNERS WITH NO DISCERNIBLE
BENEFIT. ALL INTERNET POSTING
ALREADY OCCURS FOR MOST
CONTRACTS. FOR STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS TO POST MEETING
MATERIALS UNDER THE BROWN ACT,
AB 2557 WOULD NOW REQUIRE THAT
CONTRACTS IN ANY RELATED
DOCUMENTS BE POSTED SEPARATELY
ON LOCAL AGENCIES INTERNET
WEBSITES. THIS IS AN EXPENSIVE
ENDEAVOR THAT WOULD REQUIRE
CONSIDERABLE INVESTMENTS IN IT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND STAFF FOR
LOCAL AGENCIES. FURTHER, THE
BILL MAKES NO ACCOMMODATION FOR
THE SMALL SUBSET OF LOCAL
AGENCIES THAT ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO MAINTAIN WEBSITES. AB 2557 IS
A SIGNIFICANT BURDEN FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AS WE RELY HEAVILY
ON TRUSTED LOCAL NONPROFITS,
SMALL BUSINESSES AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERS TO DELIVER CORE
SERVICES, ESPECIALLY FOR
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS. IN MY
COUNTY, FOR INSTANCE, NORTH
COAST OPPORTUNITIES AS MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE WILL BE AWARE,
NORTH COAST OPPORTUNITIES IS
PARTNERING WITH CAL OES, CAL
FIRE AND THE COUNTY OF LAKE TO
IMPLEMENT THE LAKE COUNTY HOME
HARDENING PROGRAM. PLEASE WRAP
UP. YOUR TIME IS ALMOST UP. WITH
THAT BEING SAID, I'LL JUST
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
THERE'S A NO VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL? PLEASE STEP FORWARD. STATE
YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. NICOLE WATERMAN, ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION, PLEASE SPEAK UP.
IT'S HARD TO HEAR YOU ALL. GOOD
MORNING, JOHNNY PINA. WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, JENNIFER FEARING,
SACRAMENTO ADVOCATE FOR
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS. ON BEHALF OF OUR
10,000 MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS, I
WAS ALSO ASKED TO EXPRESS THE
OPPOSITION OF THE 109 NONPROFITS
THAT MAKE UP THE INLAND EMPIRE
COMMUNITY COLLABORATIVE, THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGENCIES, AND PATH, ONE
OF THE STATE'S LARGEST HOMELESS
SERVICES PROVIDERS. HI,
JACQUELINE WONG HERNANDEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES, REPRESENTING ALL 58
COUNTIES IN OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY TO THIS BILL AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION.
ALSO IN OPPOSITION. JAMIE MINER,
ON BEHALF OF EASTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT, RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. BURGESS, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES, RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. GOOD MORNING, KIARA
ROSS, ON BEHALF OF THE TOWN OF
TRUCKEE AND THE MARIN COUNTY
COUNCIL OF MAYORS AND COUNCIL
MEMBERS, RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR CHRIS
MICHELI, ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE, IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION, THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
BED. FRANCO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND THE FIRE
DISTRICT ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING, PAUL
BHATTACHARJEE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS. KAREN LANG,
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS AND THE COUNTIES OF
BUTTE, FRESNO, KERN, HUMBOLDT,
MERCED, PLACER, SAN JOAQUIN,
SHASTA AND STANISLAUS, AS WELL
AS THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION, WHICH IS A
REPRESENTATION OF PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE ANIMAL SHELTERS. SO BOTH
SIDES OF THE COIN ON THAT ONE.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, DOROTHY
JOHNSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION, AND ALSO ON BEHALF
OF MY COLLEAGUE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY VETERAN
SERVICE OFFICERS, OPPOSED. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. KEISHA HUNT WITH
NOSSAMAN WITH THE COUNTY OF
MONTEREY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. CASSANDRA MÀ, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF DOWNEY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. MORNING.
DON KOEPKE ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION CENTER IN
CALIFORNIA, FAMILY RESOURCE
ASSOCIATION, IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BLAKE JOHNSON, ON BEHALF OF
CHILD ACTION INCORPORATED AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. MORNING
BILL WITH THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
OF ENGINEERING COMPANIES IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING, RYAN
SOUZA, ON BEHALF OF THE EMS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
MEALS ON WHEELS, CALIFORNIA, AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING, ASHLEY LUGO, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING, ALYSSA
SALEHI, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RECREATION AND PARK DISTRICTS,
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES
OF BAKERSFIELD, CARLSBAD,
CORONA, FOSTER CITY, MERCED,
SANTA ROSA, AND THE TOWN OF
HILLSBORO. IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. CORY SALZILLO, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION. IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING. JOSH
GAGER, ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA, THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS,
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION, AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS ALL
OPPOSED. JEFF NEAL, REPRESENTING
THE COUNTY OF CONTRA COSTA AND
THE CITY OF VISALIA, BOTH.
ANDREW MENDOZA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS IN
OPPOSITION. MORNING. MADAM CHAIR
AARON AVERY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. ALSO, ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. JASON
EICHER, ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN STAFFING ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA STAFFING
PROFESSIONALS. ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING,
MICHAEL GILL, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS, REPRESENTING
30,000 SCHOOL LEADERS, SCHOOL
BUSINESS LEADERS STATEWIDE IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING, ASHLEY
HOFFMAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
THANK YOU. OKAY. WE WILL MOVE
THE CONVERSATION TO MEMBERS.
LET'S GO AHEAD. SENATOR LAIRD,
SINCE EVERYBODY'S RUSHING
FORWARD, THIS BILL, HAS BEEN
VERY DIFFICULT FOR ME. AND I
HAVE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM
AND A COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THE
SPONSORS AND I THINK TO NOT GIVE
TREMENDOUSLY LONG COMMENT. I'M A
FORMER NONPROFIT DIRECTOR AND A
NONPROFIT DIRECTOR FOR AN AIDS
AGENCY. AT A TIME WHEN
GOVERNMENT WOULDN'T DO SO MANY
DIFFERENT THINGS, WE WERE DOING,
IT COULDN'T SAY SO MANY THINGS
THAT WE WERE SAYING. AND SO I
REALLY VALUE THAT AND DON'T WANT
TO FEEL LIKE ANYTHING IS AIMED
AT THAT. AND THE AUTHOR, IN A
VERY HEARTFELT COMMENT, ASSURED
ME THAT THAT WAS NOT HER INTENT
OR NOT HER GOAL. AND I RESPECT
THAT. AND I BELIEVE IT. I THINK
THIS IS JUST THE FIRST VERSION
WAS WAS VERY DIFFICULT, AND I
THINK IT'S BEEN HARD TO REEL IT
BACK. I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF THE CHAIR, BUT I DON'T
THINK IT TAKES AWAY SOME OF MY
CONCERNS AND SO I AM NOT GOING
TO SUPPORT THE BILL. BUT WHAT I
WOULD, SAY IS I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE THINGS THAT THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS ARE REALLY TRYING
TO DO, AND WHETHER IT'S SOME OF
THE CONTRACTING THAT MIGHT HAVE
BEEN RELATED TO THE CHANGE IN
INCARCERATION TO THE LOCAL
LEVEL, OR WHETHER IT'S ACTUALLY
JUST SALARIES AND BENEFITS FOR
NONPROFIT OR NON-GOVERNMENT
GROUPS, IT'S LIKE, I AM TOTALLY
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON THAT. IF
THERE ARE BILLS THAT ARE FOCUSED
RIGHT AT THAT. AND I THINK
THAT'S THE DIFFICULT THING. AND,
AND BECAUSE I RECOGNIZE ONE
THING AND WE TALKED ABOUT IT,
THE SALARIES ARE NOT VERY GOOD
IN THE NONPROFIT SECTOR IN
GENERAL. AND WHEN I WAS, HEADING
THAT PARTICULAR NONPROFIT, WE
WERE DOING GOD'S WORK AND SO THE
RATIO BETWEEN MY SALARY IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND THE
LOWEST PAID ONE WAS 2 TO 1,
BECAUSE WE WERE COMMITTED TO
DOING WHAT IT NEEDED TO BE DONE.
AND I GET THE FACT THAT THERE
MIGHT BE ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED IN THAT. BUT, SO JUST
HARD VOTE. BUT I APPRECIATE THE
WORK AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
MOVING AHEAD AND FIGURING OUT
HOW TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE THE CONCERNS
BEHIND THIS BILL. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU, SENATOR
CORTESE. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR,
AND APPRECIATE, YOU KNOW,
OBSERVING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND YOUR WORK, YOU KNOW, TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR, TO GET US TO
THIS POINT, I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL. I THINK
IT'S REALLY INTERESTING,
LISTENING CLOSELY TO, MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA CRUZ HERE
TALKING ABOUT, LIVED EXPERIENCE.
AND I CAME OUT OF AN ERA AT THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE, WHERE WE PUT
TOGETHER SOME OF THE MOST
AGGRESSIVE SUNSHINE ORDINANCES
IN THE COUNTRY. NOT BECAUSE
THERE WAS ANY PARTICULAR PROBLEM
WITH, THE NONPROFIT SECTOR OR
PROFESSIONAL LOBBYISTS OR ANY
ONE SECTOR. IT'S JUST BECAUSE
THE GOVERNMENT HAD GOTTEN VERY
BIG. AND IT WASN'T VERY
TRANSPARENT WHAT WAS GOING ON,
YOU KNOW, IN TERMS OF CONTRACTS
AND PEOPLE WANTED TO KNOW AND
PEOPLE WANTED TO KNOW IN A WAY
THAT WAS USER FRIENDLY FOR THEM
NOT HAVE TO GO THROUGH, YOU KNOW,
TEDIOUS, YOU KNOW, PROCUREMENT
DOCUMENTS TO TRY TO FIGURE
THINGS OUT. SO I THINK THAT'S
KIND OF BEEN THE INTENT HERE. I
WENT TO THE COUNTY OF SANTA
CLARA, AND WITH MY COLLEAGUE KEN
YEAGER, COAUTHORED THE FIRST
SUNSHINE ORDINANCE IN THE
HISTORY OF THE COUNTY, AS KIND
OF A NEXT STEP BASED ON WHAT WE
HAD LEARNED OVER THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE. THERE HAS TO BE
LIMITATIONS. AND IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERYONE'S TRIED TO STRIKE A
BALANCE HERE, SO THAT THERE'S
NOT TOO MUCH BURDEN ON THOSE WHO
HAVE TO DO THE REPORTING.
INCLUDING THE COUNTY ITSELF, BUT
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT MOST OF THIS
INFORMATION SHOULD BE READILY
AVAILABLE. AND I KNOW, I KNOW IN
MY HOME COUNTY, OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS, THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF ADDED REQUIREMENTS ON
ACCOUNTABILITY. YOU KNOW, COMING
OUT OF THE DEEP RECESSION,
PEOPLE LEARNED OR FELT LIKE THEY
LEARNED AT THE ELECTED DAIS
THAT, YOU KNOW, WE REALLY HAVE
TO HAVE PEOPLE AT LEAST SOMEWHAT
FREQUENTLY REPORTING BACK TO US
ON, ON OUTCOMES, ARE WE GETTING
THOSE OUTCOMES? WE TALK ABOUT IT
HERE A LOT IN ANY NUMBER OF
WAYS. YOU KNOW, AT THE STATE
LEVEL, WHICH IS AN EVEN BIGGER
GOVERNMENT THAT'S EVEN HARDER TO
FIGURE OUT SOMETIMES WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN TERMS OF OUTCOMES
WITH YOUR PROCUREMENT. BUT, BUT
ANYWAY, THIS JUST IT'S JUST MY
BACKGROUND. I CAN SEE, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS VERY MUCH ABOUT WORKLOAD
AND BURDEN AND DOING THIS, I
DOUBT VERY SERIOUSLY ANYBODY IS,
GOING TO WALK UP AND SAY, I JUST
HATE TRANSPARENCY. YOU KNOW,
IT'S A QUESTION OF HOW MUCH
PEOPLE CAN DO. AND I'M JUST
GOING TO GO WITH ENOUGH WORK HAS
BEEN DONE HERE. YOU KNOW, THE
AUTHOR, YOU KNOW, DIVED INTO IT,
A DIFFICULT AREA AND IT SEEMED
TO STRIKE A BALANCE HERE. WITH
THE COMMITTEE. SO I'LL BE AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
CORTESE, AND THANK YOU TO YOU,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA, FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD. IT'S
A VERY CHALLENGING ISSUE BECAUSE
WE REALLY LOVE AND APPRECIATE
OUR NONPROFITS AND WE ABSOLUTELY
LOVE AND APPRECIATE OUR PUBLIC
SECTOR WORKERS, I WOULD TAKE
EXCEPTION WITH SOMETHING THAT
WAS SAID BY THE OPPOSITION, WE
CAN'T BE IN THE BUSINESS OF
DOING WORK CHEAPER, I THINK THAT
IS A ZERO SUM ARGUMENT AND I
DON'T THINK IS WHERE MY DECISION
CAME TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON
THESE AMENDMENTS, BECAUSE THE
PUBLIC SECTOR HAS TO SET AN
EXAMPLE FOR WHAT GOOD WAGES AND
GOOD BENEFITS, AND TO BE PAID SO
THAT ALL OF THAT PUBLIC SECTOR
WORK AND ENGAGEMENT HAS DIGNITY.
AT THE SAME TIME, NONPROFITS AS
AS SENATOR LAIRD MENTIONED, I
COME OUT OF A NONPROFIT WORKERS
RIGHTS SPACE. AND THE WORK THAT
THE NONPROFIT DOES IS VERY
DIFFERENT IN TERMS OF THE
APPROACHES TO GETTING THE WORK
DONE. AND I THINK WE NEED THAT
FLEXIBILITY OF THE APPROACH, YOU
KNOW, MEETING WORKERS AT
MIDNIGHT, YOU KNOW, SPEAKING 22
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES, BEING ABLE
TO, YOU KNOW, ANSWER THE PHONE
WHEN THE WORKER IS NOT ABLE TO
SUBMIT SOMETHING. THAT'S WHAT
NONPROFITS DO, THAT WE DON'T
EXPECT OUR PUBLIC SECTOR WORKERS
TO DO. AND SO I THINK WE HAVE TO
RESPECT THAT. WE BRING SOMETHING
TO THE TABLE OF SERVING. AND I
THINK THIS BILL, HELPS TO, YOU
KNOW, RESPECT AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC SECTOR, BUT ALSO ENSURE
THAT WE KEEP OUR TRUSTED
NONPROFITS, IN OUR ECOSYSTEM TO
SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES. SO I'M
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL AND
WILL ASK YOU TO CLOSE. THANK YOU.
SENATORS. YOU KNOW, I WILL CLOSE
WITH RESTATING WHAT I TOLD
SENATOR LAIRD ON THE PHONE THIS
MORNING. THIS BILL HAS NEVER
BEEN ABOUT PUNISHING ANYONE. I
GREW UP IN OAKLAND. CITY THAT
DIDN'T HAVE A LOT OF RESOURCES
IN A NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE KIDS
WERE EITHER IN, YOU KNOW, DEAD
AND DRUGS OR DROPPING OUT OF
SCHOOL. AND IT WAS A NONPROFIT
SECTORS AND COMMUNITY THAT
HELPED RAISE ME, THAT HELPED
PROVIDE THE SERVICES THAT I
NEEDED TO BE HERE TODAY AS A
STATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND I
WORK WITH OUR NONPROFITS
CONSISTENTLY. I UPLIFT THEM JUST
LIKE WE ALL DO WHEN WE BRING
THEM UP HERE AND CELEBRATE THEIR
WORK. SO THIS HAS NEVER BEEN
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT OUR
NONPROFITS ARE, YOU KNOW, DOING
GOD'S WORK BECAUSE THEY ARE. BUT
THIS HAS TO BE ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY, ACCOUNTABILITY AND
RESULTS. AS A STATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, I WAS ELECTED BY THE
VOTERS TO ASK THESE QUESTIONS
AND TO BE ABLE TO DELIVER WITH
THEIR TAXPAYER DOLLARS. ARE
THINGS WORKING? ARE THEY NOT?
AND THAT'S ALL I'VE BEEN ASKING
FOR. THAT'S. AND I APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS. THIS IS WHY
WE'VE BEEN WORKING SO HARD WITH
YOUR COMMITTEE TO STRIKE THE
BALANCE. AND I WILL CONTINUE TO
UPLIFT OUR COMMUNITY AND THOSE
WHO ARE DOING WHAT WE NEED THEM
TO DO. WHEN GOVERNMENT CANNOT
STEP IN, SO WE RESPECTFULLY, ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT. I GET A MOTION
FROM YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR
CORTESE ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON. FINAL ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN. A B2557. THIS MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. I WILK
CORTEZ. CORTEZ I DURAZO. LAIRD.
LAIRD NO. WE HAVE A VOTE OF 2 TO
1. THIS BILL IS ON CALL. PICK IT
UP WHEN WE HAVE MORE OF OUR
QUORUM HERE. THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB 2499. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BROUGH.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB 2499 TO YOU TODAY. NO
PERSON SHOULD LOSE A JOB BECAUSE
THEY NEED TIME TO RECOVER FROM A
TRAUMATIC OR VIOLENT EVENT. AB
2499 WILL ENSURE THAT FAMILY
MEMBERS OF LIVING DIRECT VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS OF TRAUMA CAN TAKE
UNPAID LEAVE AS TIME OFF TO
ADDRESS SAFETY CONCERNS, HEAL OR
SUPPORT THEIR FAMILY. 1 IN 6
SURVIVORS OF VIOLENT CRIME
REPORT LOSING THEIR JOB OR BEING
DEMOTED BECAUSE THEY NEEDED TO
TAKE TIME OFF FOLLOWING A
TRAUMATIC EVENT. 53% OVER HALF
OF SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE REPORT LOSING A JOB
BECAUSE OF THE ABUSE. SEVEN OUT
OF TEN VICTIMS DESCRIBE FEELING
UNSAFE OR SCARED FOLLOWING BEING
A VICTIM OF A CRIME. LOW WAGE
WORKERS, INCLUDING IMMIGRANTS,
WOMEN, NON-BINARY WORKERS AND
WORKERS OF COLOR WHO ARE
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE TO
VIOLENCE, ARE ALSO THE LEAST
LIKELY TO HAVE EXISTING
FLEXIBILITY OR LEAVE PROTECTIONS
AT THEIR JOBS. WE WORKED WITH
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
THAT HAVE LIMITED THE AMOUNT OF
LEAVE TO TWO WEEKS OR TEN DAYS,
ALONG WITH LIMITING THE REASONS
FOR LEAVE. ADDITIONALLY, LEAVE
IS AGAIN UNPAID AND IS ONLY
AVAILABLE AND USABLE FOR COVERED
REASONS. EXPERIENCING VIOLENCE
DOES NOT ENTITLE A WORKER OR
THEIR FAMILY MEMBER TO SIMPLY
TAKE WEEKS OFF OF WORK. FEWER
THAN 215 COMPLAINTS HAVE BEEN
MADE TO THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
BASED ON THE SURVIVOR'S RIGHTS
IN THE LAST THREE YEARS, WHICH
IS DATA THAT'S AVAILABLE, AND
THE CRD EXPECTS ONLY 50 TO 100
COMPLAINTS PER YEAR. EMPLOYERS
WILL BENEFIT AS WELL, FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES WILL BE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO RETURN TO WORK, MORE
ABLE TO WORK, AND FOCUS WHEN
GIVEN THE APPROPRIATE TIME TO
RECOVER. JOINING ME TODAY IS
MANNY SANCHEZ FROM CRIME
SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE. AND ALSO A SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY, SHAZZY KARMALI, WITH
LEGAL AID AT WORK, TO TESTIFY.
GOOD MORNING. CHAIR. SENATORS.
MY NAME IS MANNY SANCHEZ, AND I
AM A MEMBER OF CRIME SURVIVORS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE. OUR
PROGRAM REPRESENTS A NETWORK OF
OVER 50,000 CRIME SURVIVORS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. I'M SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2499. I CAME TO
BE A MEMBER OF CRIME SURVIVORS
OF SAFETY AND JUSTICE DUE TO THE
MURDER OF MY DAUGHTER, JUSTICE.
JUSTICE WAS TAKEN FROM US WAY
TOO YOUNG BY GUN VIOLENCE. IT
WAS ONLY 19 YEARS OLD. SHE HAD
GOALS AND DREAMS. SHE WAS VERY
LOVING AND CARING WITH SUCH A
BEAUTIFUL SMILE. SHE WAS A SMART
YOUNG WOMAN WHO STILL HAD HER
WHOLE LIFE AHEAD OF HER. WHEN
JUSTICE PASSED, I HAVE STILL
BEEN IN THE PROCESS OF HEALING.
MY MOM HAD JUST PASSED AWAY AND
I HAD NO MORE TIME OFF TO USE. I
STRUGGLED TO TAKE TIME OFF TO
MEET WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT. I
NEEDED TO HELP MY STEPDAUGHTER
GET HER MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT
FOR HER PROCESS FOR HER GRIEF. I
NEEDED TIME TO MEET WITH FUNERAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS. I'M STILL IN
THE PROCESS OF HEALING IN MY
GRIEF. IT'S GOING ON TWO YEARS
SINCE JUSTICE PASSED AND I STILL
STRUGGLE TO TAKE TIME OFF FOR
GRIEVING WITHOUT HAVING THE FEAR
OF LOSING MY JOB. WE, AS
SURVIVORS, NEED THIS BILL TO
BECOME LAW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR TAKING YOUR TIME TO HEAR OUR
STORIES. YOU GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS SHASHI KARMALI AND I AM
A STAFF ATTORNEY AT LEGAL AID AT
WORK, A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
THAT PROVIDES LEGAL
REPRESENTATION AND ADVOCACY FOR
WORKERS ACROSS THE STATE. I'M
HERE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT AB
2499, WHICH WILL STRENGTHEN
WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS FOR
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CRIME WORKERS SEEK OUT OUR LEGAL
SERVICES BECAUSE THEY ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR SAFETY,
BUT ALSO BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
SURE WHAT THEY CAN DO TO STAY
SAFE WITHOUT RISKING THEIR JOB.
AND MAINTAINING EMPLOYMENT IS
CRITICAL TO MAINTAINING THE
BRIDGE TO FINANCIAL
INDEPENDENCE, WHICH EMPOWERS
SURVIVORS AND ALLOWS THEM TO
HEAL AND MOVE ON. AB 2499
ADDRESSES GAPS IN EXISTING LAW
BY ADDING ADDITIONAL SPECIFIC
REASONS. SURVIVORS AND THEIR
CLOSE FAMILY MEMBERS CAN ACCESS
UNPAID LEAVE, WHICH IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. IT ALLOWS A PARENT TO
TAKE LEAVE FOR A DAY TO HELP
THEIR DAUGHTER MOVE FROM AN
ABUSIVE HOME, OR FOR A SIBLING
TO HOLD THEIR SISTER'S HAND IN
COURT. AND THOSE THINGS CAN MAKE
A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SOMEONE
ACHIEVING SAFETY OR EXPERIENCING
CONTINUED. AB 2499 ALSO EXPANDS
ACCESS TO REASONABLE SAFETY
ACCOMMODATIONS AT WORK. TO THOSE
WHO EXPERIENCE ALL TYPES OF
VIOLENCE, AND TO FAMILY MEMBERS
WHO NEED AN ACCOMMODATION FOR
THEIR OWN SAFETY. FINALLY, AB
2499 ALSO MOVES SURVIVORS
WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS FROM THE
LABOR CODE INTO THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT SO
THAT WORKERS CAN SEEK JUSTICE
WITHOUT HAVING TO FILE WITH
MULTIPLE STATE AGENCIES. SAFETY
FOR SURVIVORS IS CRITICAL FOR A
JUST AND HEALTHY CALIFORNIA, AND
AB 2499 IS WILL TAKE COMMON
SENSE STEPS TO BETTER ENSURE
SURVIVORS CAN ACHIEVE SAFETY
WITHOUT HAVING TO LOSE THEIR
JOBS. AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY WE
WILL MOVE TO SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
STATE YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. MY NAME IS CONCEPCION
SANCHEZ, THE MOTHER OF JUSTICE,
AND I AM A MEMBER OF CRIME
SURVIVOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE. AND
I'M FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS ED LITTLE, ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND CRIME. SURVIVORS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE, PRO
CO-SPONSOR. THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, IVONNE
FERNANDEZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT. MORNING AGAIN. BRYANT
MIRAMONTEZ WITH AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE, COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? OKAY. LET'S MOVE TO
OPPOSITION. WHEN WISHING TO BE A
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION, PLEASE
HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE. JUST A
ME TOO. OH, YEAH, ASHLEY HOFFMAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. I JUST REALLY WANTED
TO THANK THE SPONSORS AND THE
AUTHORS OFFICE FOR WORKING WITH
US ON AMENDMENTS ARE ONLY
OUTSTANDING. CONCERN IS JUST A
GENERAL CONCERN THAT THAT THIS
WOULD BE THE 10TH NEW LEAVE OR
EXPANSION OF LEAVE, JUST THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. BUT AGAIN,
REALLY WANT TO THANK THE AUTHORS
OF THIS. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIR MEMBERS, MARTIN
LARA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE CAL CHAMBER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS
CHAMBER. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR CORTESE. WE WILL WAIT. I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE TO TAKE THIS
UP. OKAY. SORRY. I WAS THINKING
ABOUT MY COUNT, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE, PLEASE? MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE AREN'T LOSING THEIR JOBS
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN A VICTIM OF
A CRIME, AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL. AND TO
THE PARENTS OF JUSTICE, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH US
AND HAVING YOUR THE COURAGE TO
SHARE YOUR STORY FOR OTHER
FAMILIES. AND NOW WE'LL HAVE THE
ASSISTANT CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM SIX. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WILK CORTEZ. CORTEZ I
DURAZO LAIRD. HAVE A VOTE OF 2
TO 0. THIS BILL IS ON CALL WHEN
WE HAVE OUR QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE
IT. THANK YOU.
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKINNEY
IS IN THE AUDIENCE. WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE NOW TO AB 2561. PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY.
FEAR AND MEMBERS, I AM HERE TO
PRESENT AB 2561, WHICH AIMS TO
TACKLE THE PERSISTENT ISSUE OF
HIGH VACANCY RATES WITHIN OUR
LOCAL AGENCIES. THESE HIGH JOB
VACANCY RATES SIGNIFICANTLY
AFFECT PUBLIC SERVICES,
DELIVERING DELIVERABLES AND
CONTRIBUTE TO WORK OUT WORK
BURNOUT. THE BILL MANDATES THAT
AGENCIES EXPERIENCE AN A 15%
VACANCY RATE FOR OVER 180 DAYS,
MUST, UPON REQUEST BY
RECOGNIZING EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATION CONVENED WITHIN 21
DAYS TO STRATEGIZE FILING THESE
POSITIONS AND HOLDING A PUBLIC
HEARING WITHIN 90 DAYS TO
ADDRESS HIRING OBSTACLES AND
STRATEGIES. IMPORTANTLY,
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS WILL BE
GRANTED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AT THESE HEARINGS
INSURANCE TRANSPARENCY AND, TO
ENSURING, TRANSPARENCY. AT ITS
HEART, AB 2561 AIMS TO ENSURE
THAT OUR ESSENTIAL PUBLIC
SERVICES ARE ADEQUATELY STAFFED
WHILE PROTECTING THE RIGHTS AND
INTERESTS OF PUBLIC EMPLOYEES BY
FOSTERING COLLABORATIVE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN PUBLIC
AGENCIES, RECOGNIZING EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATIONS. THIS LEGISLATION
PROMOTES TRANSPARENCY,
EFFICIENCY, STAFFING, PRACTICE,
AND POSITIVE LABOR RELATIONS.
INITIALLY, THE BILL REQUIRED A
FULL ASSESSMENT OF RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION PROCESSES AND A
VACANCY PLAN. WE AMENDED THE
BILL TO GIVE WORKERS A VOICE,
ENSURING CLEAR STEPS TO ADDRESS
STAFFING ISSUES AND ALLOWING
PUBLIC INPUT. THIS PROCESS IS
ACTIVATED ONLY IF AN AGENCY
DEPARTMENT HAS A HIGH VACANCY
EXCEEDING SIX MONTHS, AND IF THE
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION REQUESTED.
THE BILL ALSO ENSURES PUBLIC
ACCESS TO EMPLOYMENT INFORMATION
AND ALLOWS COST REIMBURSEMENT
THROUGH LEGAL MEANS. I AND I
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT THROUGH
THESE MEASURES, WE COULD
STRENGTHEN OUR PUBLIC WORKFORCE
AND BETTER SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES. I AM COMMITTED TO
MAKING ANY NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS
TO ENSURE THE BILL'S
EFFECTIVENESS. OUR ULTIMATE GOAL
IS TO FOSTER ONGOING DIALOG WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS THE
LABOR CRISIS FACING LOCAL
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA. WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
THE BILL IS BRIAN FROM AFSCME
AND IVAN FERNANDEZ WITH
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF LABOR.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. YOU MAY
PROCEED. YOU. HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. YVONNE
FERNANDO, WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION, A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR OF AB 2561 LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
PUBLIC SERVICES THAT
CALIFORNIANS RELY ON EVERY DAY.
THESE SERVICES ARE PROVIDED
THANKS TO THE HARD WORK OF OUR
PUBLIC SECTOR WORKERS SUCH AS
NURSES, FIREFIGHTERS, SANITATION
WORKERS AND SO MANY OTHER
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVICE
WORKERS. HOWEVER, DUE TO
WIDESPREAD VACANCIES UP TO 30%
IN SOME COUNTIES, WORKERS SUCH
AS PUBLIC AGENCIES ARE
CHRONICALLY UNDERSTAFFED AND
STRUGGLE TO PROVIDE BASIC
SERVICES. AS A RESULT, OUR
PUBLIC SECTOR WORKERS FACE
INCREASED WORKLOADS, MANDATORY
OVERTIME, AND STRESS OF TRYING
TO DO MULTIPLE JOBS AT ONCE.
THIS HAS LED TO WORKER BURNOUT
AND HIGHER TURNOVER RATES ONLY
WORSENING THE VACANCY CRISIS
THAT WE ARE EXPERIENCING. THIS
IS AN UNFORTUNATE REALITY
CONSIDERING THAT PUBLIC SECTOR
JOBS ONCE PROVIDED PATHWAYS
TOWARDS HOME OWNERSHIP AND
FINANCIAL STABILITY FOR SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS, AB 2561 WILL
ADDRESS THE VACANCY CRISIS BY
REQUIRING LOCAL AGENCIES WITH
HIGH DEPARTMENTAL VACANCY RATES
TO MEET AND CONFER WITH IMPACTED
UNIONS TO DISCUSS AND DEVELOP
STRATEGIES TO FILL VACANCIES. IN
ADDITION TO MEETING WITH THE
IMPACTED UNION, A PUBLIC HEARING
WILL BE HELD FOR PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT. HB 2561 IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION AT
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF LOCAL
VACANCIES, AND FOR THESE
REASONS, WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
BRIAN, BRIAN MIRAMONTEZ WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE,
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES, WE
REPRESENT OVER 200,000 WORKERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN THE
PUBLIC SERVICE, I FIRST WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. THIS
ISSUE IS A HUGE PRIORITY FOR OUR
FOLKS, WE ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK AND THE CHAIR'S
WORK ON THIS BILL AS WELL. SO
I'LL START WITH JUST SHARING OUR
MEMBERS PROVIDE CRITICAL
SERVICES TO COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THROUGH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITHIN EACH
DISTRICT, THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
HOWEVER, DUE TO LOCAL AGENCIES
FAILURE TO HIRE AND RETAIN CIVIL
SERVANTS INTO THE PUBLIC SECTOR
WORKFORCE, OUR MEMBERS ARE BEING
OVERWORKED AND OVEREXTENDED. THE
UC BERKELEY LABOR CENTER
RELEASED A REPORT IN DECEMBER,
CITING VARIOUS FIXABLE ISSUES
THAT ARE CREATING BARRIERS TO
RETENTION AND RECRUITMENT ACROSS
SEVERAL COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA,
SUCH AS POOR WORKING CONDITIONS,
UNCOMPETITIVE COMPENSATION, AND
ARDUOUS HIRING PROCESS, ALL OF
WHICH, AGAIN, ARE ADDRESSABLE
AND FIXABLE. A STATE AUDIT OF
THE AE RELEASED JUST LAST MONTH,
SHOWED THAT THEY WERE BACKLOGGED
47,000 CASES AND SPECIFICALLY
CITED NOT ONLY THE STAFFING
SHORTAGES AS THE MAIN ISSUE IN
ADDRESSING THE BACKLOG, BUT THE
UTTER LACK OF URGENCY OF THE
OFFICE OR THE DIR TO
MEANINGFULLY DO ANYTHING ABOUT
IT OR MAKE ANY MEANINGFUL
CHANGES TO THEIR HIRING
PROCEDURES. CLEARLY, THE CURRENT
PROCESS FOR ADDRESSING RETENTION
RECRUITMENT IS NOT WORKING. THIS
IS WHY WE NEED THIS BILL. AB
2561 HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY
AMENDED, AND THE NEW LANGUAGE
SIMPLY DOES TWO THINGS. AS THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STATED, IF ANY,
IF AND ONLY IF THE AGENCY HAS
HIGH DEPARTMENTAL DEPARTMENTAL
VACANCY RATES AND IF THE UNION
REQUESTS IT, AGENCY WOULD SIT
DOWN WITH THE UNION TO DISCUSS
WHAT IS CAUSING THE AGENCIES TO,
FOR EXAMPLE, TAKE 6 TO 8 MONTHS
TO GET BACK TO A CANDIDATE OR
NOT PROVIDE FLEXIBLE WORKING
CONDITIONS WHEN THEY CAN'T, OR
NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE COMPETITIVE
COMPENSATION SIMILAR TO THOSE IN
THE SURROUNDING AREAS. IN BOTH
THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTORS.
THEN THEY WOULD USE THIS INFO TO
IDENTIFY STEPS TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM, AND AFTER SITTING DOWN,
THEY WOULD HOLD A PUBLIC HEARING
ON THE ISSUE, ALLOWING MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY TO WEIGH IN. TO
WRAP UP. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
GIVING THE AFFECTED AND
OVERWORKED WORKFORCE A VOICE AND
HOLDING OUR LOCAL PUBLIC LEADERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR BEING BETTER
EMPLOYERS. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. OKAY, WE WILL TURN TO
THOSE IN SUPPORT. PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS TERRY BRENNAN, ON
BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA, YOU
WOULD THINK THIS IS JUST COMMON
SENSE. I'M APPALLED THAT WE HAVE
TO REQUIRE EMPLOYERS TO SIT DOWN
WITH THE PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY DO
THE JOB TO FIND OUT HOW TO MAKE
IT BETTER. SO I APPLAUD THE BILL
AND THE AUTHOR. THANK YOU. JUST
A REMINDER, NAME, AFFILIATION
AND POSITION CHRIS MYERS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS
DOUG SUBERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT. OKAY.
TURNING TO OPPOSITION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WILL BE A
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION? IF YOU
ARE WITNESS, PLEASE HAVE A SEAT
AT THE TABLE. YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS JASON BRITT
AND I AM THE COUNTY
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER FOR
TULARE COUNTY. I HAVE ALSO
SERVED TULARE COUNTY FOR 30
YEARS, BEGINNING MY CAREER AS
THE ELIGIBILITY WORKER. I'VE
ALSO SERVED AS THE PUBLIC
GUARDIAN SOCIAL SERVICES
DIRECTOR, PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTOR
AND HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY DIRECTOR. ALL THIS TO SAY
THAT MY ROOTS AND COMMITMENT IN
TULARE AND COUNTY GOVERNMENT RUN
DEEP AND ARE SINCERE. I'M
INVESTED IN MY WORKFORCE AND I
BELIEVE MY FELLOW FELLOW COUNTY
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICERS ARE
EQUALLY INVESTED. TULARE COUNTY
IS A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES,
WHICH IS PART OF A LARGE
COALITION OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
GROUPS OPPOSED TO AB 2561.
COUNTIES FACE MANY CHALLENGES
RELATED TO THE RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION, INCLUDING REBOUNDING
FROM THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC, THE
GREAT RESIGNATION LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMPETING WITH
PRIVATE SECTOR FOR A LIMITED
HIRING POOL, COUNTIES WHO, BY
THE WAY, ARE ON THE FRONT LINE
DELIVERING SERVICES ON YOUR
BEHALF. BUT BOTH HAVE LONG TERM
VACANCY RATES, BOTH ON CURRENT
EMPLOYEES AND THE RESIDENTS WHO
RECEIVE SERVICES FROM THOSE
DEPARTMENTS. WE UNDERSTAND AND
RECOGNIZE THOSE IMPACTS.
COUNTIES HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTING
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO TRY TO BOOST
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION AND
INCREASE RETENTION. YET MANY
SPECIALTY POSITIONS LIKE NURSES,
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS,
SOCIAL WORKERS AND SHERIFFS ARE
EXPERIENCING A NATIONWIDE
SHORTAGE AND DWINDLING PIPELINE
FOR NEW ENTRANTS. WORKFORCE
CHALLENGES IMPACT ALL COUNTIES,
BUT RURAL COUNTIES TEND TO FILL
THESE CHALLENGES, MOST DUE TO
LIMITED FINANCIAL RESOURCES AND
OFTEN MORE LIMITED NUMBER OF
AVAILABLE WORKERS TO HIRE. IF
THE TRUE INTENT OF AB 2561 IS TO
PROVIDE A PATH FOR PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO REDUCE REDUCE STAFF
VACANCIES, THEN DIVERTING STAFF
TIME AWAY FROM CORE SERVICE
DELIVERY AND FORCING NUMEROUS
ADDITIONAL MEET AND CONFERS ON
AN UNREASONABLE 21 DAY TIMELINE
WILL NOT ACHIEVE THAT GOAL. THE
TOTAL IMPACT OF WHAT FEELS LIKE
UNENDING STATE MANDATES, WITHOUT
ADEQUATE FUNDING AND
FLEXIBILITIES CONTRIBUTES TO
VACANCY RATES, ADDING ANOTHER
UNFUNDED, ANOTHER 30S THE
MANDATE ON COUNTIES LIKE MINE
WILL NOT FILL VACANCIES AND
INCUMBENT. IT IS INCUMBENT UPON
ALL OF US TO MAKE PUBLIC SERVICE
ATTRACTIVE. THEREFORE, I'M
ASKING YOU TO RESPECTFULLY VOTE
NO ON AB 2561. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, I'M LISA
MURPHY. I'M THE DEPUTY CITY
MANAGER FOR THE CITY OF SANTA
CRUZ AND THE FORMER HUMAN
RESOURCES DIRECTOR FOR THE CITY
OF SANTA CRUZ FOR EIGHT YEARS.
I'VE BEEN IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FOR OVER 24 YEARS, AND I ALSO
STAND BEFORE YOU AS THE
IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
PERSONNEL AND EMPLOYEE RELATIONS
DEPARTMENT. ASSEMBLY BILL 2561
FAILS TO ADDRESS THE CRITICAL
ISSUES OF FILLING VACANT
POSITIONS. IN FACT, THIS BILL
WILL EXTEND THE PROCESS, CREATE
LAYERS OF BUREAUCRATIC
PAPERWORK, AND PREVENT LIMITED
STAFF RESOURCES FROM ACTUALLY
FILLING VACANT POSITIONS. WHILE
WE ALL STRIVE FOR HIGHLY
QUALIFIED AND FULLY STAFFED
WORKFORCE, THE PROPOSED
REQUIREMENTS DO NOT ALIGN WITH
PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS MANDATING
EXTENSIVE PLANS WILL NOT RESOLVE
THE FUNDAMENTAL CHALLENGE OF
FILLING SPECIALIZED ROLES LIKE
CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS OR
ELECTRICIANS WERE OFTENTIMES
PRIVATE SECTOR COMPENSATION
SIGNIFICANTLY OUTSTRIPS PUBLIC
SECTOR OFFERS. THIS LEGISLATION
APPEARS TO CIRCUMVENT
TRADITIONAL BARGAINING PROCESSES
BY PRESSURING CITIES LIKE THE
CITY OF SANTA CRUZ INTO YEAR
ROUND NEGOTIATIONS ON INDIVIDUAL
COMPENSATION AND WORKING
CONDITIONS, RATHER THAN FAIR AND
COMPREHENSIVE UNION CONTRACTS
FOR EVERYONE. THIS IS AN EFFORT
TO CIRCUMVENT THE MYERS MILIUS
BROWN ACT BY REQUIRING PUBLIC
HEARINGS BEFORE THE CITY
COUNCIL, RATHER THAN MEETING AND
CLEARING AND CONFERRING IN GOOD
FAITH. THE DIFFICULTIES IN
FILLING POSITIONS EXTEND BEYOND
MERE BUREAUCRATIC TIMELINES OR
ARBITRARY VACANCY RATES. THEY'RE
COMPOUNDED BY EXTERNAL FACTORS
LIKE VARYING MUNICIPAL BUDGETS
AND COMPETITIVE PRIVATE SECTOR
SALARIES, AND THE LACK OF
ENTHUSIASM. QUITE FRANKLY, FOR
THE PUBLIC SECTOR. IF THE CITY
IS NOT ABLE TO FULFILL THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE PLAN AS
REQUIRED BY THIS BILL, THE
UNIONS WILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO
FILE AN UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE
CHARGE WITH PERB, WHICH WILL
ALLOW FOR A UNION TO GO ON
STRIKE, WHICH ULTIMATELY HURTS
THE WORKERS IN THE COMMUNITY.
THIS WILL NOT FILL POSITIONS IN
THE CITY OF SANTA CRUZ. IF WE
HAD ONE OF OUR EMPLOYEE UNIONS,
WHICH HAS 72 EMPLOYEES, IF WE
HAD A 15% VACANCY RATE, THAT'S
11 POSITIONS THAT WE'D HAVE TO
CREATE AN INDIVIDUAL PLAN ON
EACH ONE OF THESE TO HAVE ABOUT
30S COULD YOU PLEASE. WE ARE
WORKING TO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE ARE WORKING ON VERY
DILIGENTLY IN THE CITY OF SANTA
CRUZ TO RESOLVE THESE PROBLEMS.
WE ARE WORKING TOGETHER WITH OUR
UNIONS IN COLLABORATION TO FILL
OUR VACANCIES. WHILE CITIES ARE
COMMITTED TO FILLING VACANCIES
OVER, THIS BILL OVERLOOKS THE
NECESSITY FOR SUSTAINABLE
REVENUE STREAMS. THANK YOU. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE A NO VOTE. IF
YOU ARE SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION,
PLEASE COME TO THE MIC, STATE
YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. NICOLE WATERMAN, ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION,
JACQUELINE WONG HERNANDEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS CATHY CENTRELINK
MACDONALD FOR THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
OPPOSITION, JAMIE MINER ON
BEHALF OF EASTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT, RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING AGAIN,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS. KAREN
LANG, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
TREASURERS AND TAX COLLECTORS,
THE BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS OF
BUTTE, DEL NORTE, FRESNO,
HUMBOLDT, MERCED, SAN LUIS
OBISPO, SHASTA, SOLANO, ALL IN
OPPOSITION THIS MORNING. THANK
YOU. MONNING ALICE IS STILL HIGH
IN OPPOSITION ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RECREATION AND PARK DISTRICT AND
ALSO THE CITIES OF BAKERSFIELD,
CARLSBAD, CORONA AND RANCHO
CUCAMONGA. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR AARON AVERY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
DANIEL SANCHEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA, IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TODAY. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR. KIARA ROSS. ON
BEHALF OF THE MARIN COUNTY
COUNCIL. MAYORS OF COUNCIL
MEMBERS. THE CITY OF SAN MARCOS
AND THE TOWN OF TRUCKEE, ALL IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. WE
KAMERICK WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. IN OPPOSITION,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION OFFICE. GOOD
MORNING. JOSH GALLAGHER ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA, THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION, THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS,
AND THE COLUSA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, ALL IN OPPOSITION.
JEFF NEAL, REPRESENTING THE
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, ALSO OPPOSED. THANK
YOU. CHAIR MEMBERS ROSS BARKLEY,
ON BEHALF OF SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT, WE
HAVE OPPOSED THIS AMENDED
POSITION. WE'VE HAD GOOD
CONVERSATIONS WITH AUTHORS,
OFFICES AND SPONSORS. THANK YOU.
OKAY. WE WILL BRING IT TO THE
DÍAS MEMBERS. QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR CORTESE. MEMBER, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? WELL, I'D I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU GUYS THIS
MORNING, THANK THE WITNESSES FOR
COMING OUT. I ALSO WAS STARTED
MY CAREER OUT AS AN ELIGIBILITY
WORKER. AND SO I WAS A PUBLIC
SECTOR WORKER FOR 25 YEARS. I
WORKED FOR DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES, AND I WAS AN AUDITOR
FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. AND SO I KNOW THE
SERVICES THAT YOU GUYS PROVIDE
AND HOW HARD YOU WORK. BUT WE
HAD SOME HEARINGS THIS YEAR ON
VACANCIES IN PUBLIC SECTOR, AND
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO START TO
FILL THESE POSITIONS. WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S PEOPLE OUT THERE
THAT NEED WORK, BUT SOME FOR
SOME REASON THERE'S A DISCONNECT
AND WE'RE NOT ACTUALLY FILLING
THOSE POSITIONS. WE KNOW THAT
THE COMMUNITY NEEDS THESE
SERVICES, AND SO THEY'RE
SUFFERING AS WELL, AND WE'RE
OVERWORKING THE FOLKS THAT ARE
THERE. AND SO WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS TRY TO HELP THAT MOVE
THAT PROCESS ALONG. I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU GUYS
THROUGHOUT HOPEFULLY MY TEN YEAR
HERE ON ON VACANCIES, BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT IT'S HARD FOR YOU GUYS
AS WELL TO CONTINUE YOUR WORK
WITH THESE TYPES OF VACANCIES.
AND I REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY. WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
CORTESE ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON. FINAL ITEM EIGHT.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS, AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WILK. WILK. NÓ. CORTEZ
CORTEZ. AYE. DURAZO LAIRD. OKAY.
WE HAVE A VOTE OF 2 TO 1. WE'RE
ON CALL. WHEN WE GET A QUORUM,
WE'LL TAKE IT UP. WHEN THE
MEMBERS RETURN, WE'LL TAKE.
ALL RIGHT. WELL WE ARE GOING TO
DO A LITTLE BIT MORE
HOUSEKEEPING WHILE WE WAIT FOR
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO ARRIVE.
HELLO, SENATOR WILK, WELCOME. I
KNOW I KNOW, WE KNOW. SO WE.
JUST A REMINDER. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB, 3043 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS WAS PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR. AND WE NOW WILL REOPEN
THE ROLL AND SORT OF START FROM
THE TOP SO YOU CAN HEAR VOTES IN.
Ã. WE WILL START WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR, ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR, WHICH TODAY IS
FILE ITEMS NUMBER THREE AND
NUMBER NINE, SENATOR WILK WILK I
DURAZZO. OKAY. WE HAVE A VOTE OF
4 TO 0. CONSENT CALENDAR STILL
ON CALL. LET'S MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE. THAT IS AB 310.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CHAIR IS VOTING AYE. SENATOR
WILK WILK. AYE DURAZZO. OKAY.
THAT BILL HAS A VOTE OF 4 TO 0.
IT IS STILL ON CALL, WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO, AB
1137. ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CHAIR IS
VOTING AYE. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 0. SENATOR WILK WILK. AYE.
DURAZZO OKAY. WE HAVE A VOTE OF
4 TO 0. THAT BILL IS STILL ON
CALL. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR, AB 2494. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR, THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. THE CHAIR IS
VOTING AYE. CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO
0. SENATOR WILK WILK. AYE.
DURAZZO THAT BILL IS A VOTE OF 4
TO 0, AND IT IS ON CALL. MOVING
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE, AB
2872, ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
ASSISTANT CALLED THE ROLL ON
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR WILK
WILK AYE. DURAZZO OKAY. THAT
BILL IS ON CALL WITH A VOTE OF 4
TO 0. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX, AB 2499. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SCHIAVO ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX, THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
TWO ZERO. SENATOR WILK WILK.
AYE. DURAZZO. LAIRD. LAIRD AYE.
4 TO 0. THAT BILL IS ON. CALL
AYE. FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN, AB
2557. ORTEGA THIS MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE
IS 2 TO 1, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR WILK WILK NØ
DURAZZO. THAT BILL HAS A VOTE OF
2 TO 2. IT IS ON CALL. MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT, AB
2561. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKENNA ON
FILE ITEM EIGHT. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 1. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. SORRY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCKENNA. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS IS
THE CHAIR. IS CURRENTLY VOTING
AYE. SENATOR WILK 2561. OH I
APOLOGIZE. YES. APOLOGIES.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 1. SENATOR
WILK. THANK YOU, SENATOR
DURAZZO. SENATOR LAIRD. LAIRD.
AYE. OKAY. WE HAVE A VOTE OF 3
TO 1. THAT BILL IS ON CALL.
SENATE. COMMITTEE ON LABOR.
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
WILL BE IN RECESS FOR FIVE
MINUTES.
THE SENATE LABOR COMMITTEE HAS
RECONVENED. WE WILL REOPEN THE
ROLL, AND WE WILL START WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND WORK OUR
WAY THROUGH, COMMITTEE
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR, WHICH
IS FILE ITEMS THREE AND NINE
TODAY. SENATOR. SENATOR DURAZZO.
DURAZZO I. WITH A VOTE OF 5 TO 0
CONSENT. CALENDAR IS OUT. MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB
310. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA.
THE MOTION FOR FILE ITEM ONE IS
DUE. PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CHAIR IS
VOTING AYE. SENATOR DURAZZO I
DURAZZO I. WITH A VOTE OF 5 TO
0, THAT BILL IS OUT. MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB 1137.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES-SAWYER
FILE ITEM TWO. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR. SENATOR DURAZZO I
DURAZZO I. FIVE ZERO. THE BILL
IS OUT MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB 2404. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON FOR FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED. THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. DURAZZO I
DURAZZO I. THE VOTE OF 5 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB 2872. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. DURAZZO I
DURAZZO I THE VOTE OF 5 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS OUT. MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE, AB 2872.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON. OKAY
SO EFFICIENT. WE ALREADY DID
THAT ONE FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
2499 ASSEMBLY MEMBER SCHIAVO FOR
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX. THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR DURAZZO,
I DURAZZO I. WITH A VOTE OF 5 TO
0, THAT BILL IS OUT. MOVING ON
TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB 2557,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA, FOR FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN, THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO TWO, WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
DURAZZO I DURAZZO I. WITH THE
VOTE OF 3 TO 2, THAT BILL IS
OUT. MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT, AB 2561. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCKENNA ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 1. SENATOR DURAZZO I
DURAZZO I. WITH A VOTE OF 4 TO
1, THAT BILL IS OUT. Þ. THAT
CONCLUDES OUR HEARING FOR SENATE
LABOR, PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SUBMIT ANY TESTIMONY, FEEL FREE
TO DO SO IN WRITING WITH THAT,
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED.